Well, I don't believe that's the exclusive thing. I think he's
targeting malicious actors. >> You believe that is the
explanatory fact why he didn't go off.
That's what he said. That's what I'm saying. >> I'm responding.
Are you going to let me speak or not? >> Address that.
So, we went down the
I would I would have this conversation for 30 hours longer with
straight raid or or JTO because they never did this. They never
did this
where they just made and then when I
about it, just have a conversation. I'll be I'll be real. Hold
on. Hold on. Hold on.
>> It's like very obvious. >> It matters to people.
Like these kinds of lies matter. And it matters when they do
it, right? It matters when Ben Ampata lies. It matters when Hassan
lies. It matters when Denim's lies. Fair. >> Yes. But I
feel like we just I we can't just skip over what I just what
I just said a moment ago, which is essentially just like not
all lies are created equal. Like we should not we should not
evaluate all lies as the same just like it's just lie equal bad.
>> No doubt. So for example in this context and many other
context when they >> what dude they they oh this is the
worst.
They basically agree
but Hutch Hutch is like fighting on the dumbest hill I've ever
seen. It's like okay I would agree that not necessarily every
lie is bad but then that's like the exception and not the rule.
And he's basically he's like consistently pausing to make sure
Pisco understands that like whoa I have to know I I can't say
lying is bad because there are some lies that could possibly
be good. It's like no you could say lying is bad outside of a
few like notable exceptions.
You don't have to like pause every single time to say no lying
could be good. What if he what if he told us that he was suing
them for copyright infringement? He's trying to protect copyright
and that lie was important. What if that lie was like morally
good? >> What if he didn't sue them for copyright? His
mom was going to be he was being held like he was being threatened.
He was under duress to the point that he had no choice but to
sue them or else his entire family would be threatened. It's
like, okay, >> they were going to they were going to nuke
New York City unless he lied about his impetus for the lawsuit.
>> Hey Ry, how's it going? >> Season's greetings.
>> What's up?
is now a bad time to ask why
this is like why you guys are upset at Hutch? >> Oh, cuz
he refuses to engage in this conversation. like really transparently
the whole time. >> Okay. Um >> and I have PTSD cuz
he did the same thing when I debated him. So I actually >> He's
also >> Yeah, he's also very passive aggressively like
trying to make Pisco look like when Pisco talks kind of annoying
a little bit. >> Okie dokie. >> I'm more offended
by his arguments truly or lack thereof than him. Him him personally
is fine or whatever. It's just like I I don't like the way that
he's being res. It's like pulling teeth trying to get answers
to very straightforward questions for some
>> Okay. So,
uh I guess what I'm more confused about is
why his position is bad on this situation because it wasn't to
my limited knowledge his position was just that
Ethan Klein could have
wanted to dig at these people but also protect his copyright.
He could have, but that's highly improbable and pretty much invalidated
by other pieces of information that Pisco brings to his attention
that he doesn't really want to contend with.
>> Uh, like what?
Like that's that's kind of what I wanted to
talk about. And if that's not uh this is not the right time for
this, you guys are in the video or something like that's fine.
>> No, we could talk about it. >> Wait, why do you
think? >> So, let's say I have the running theory that
that's the reason. Well, I I don't see why that position possible.
>> Uh, from where I currently stand, yeah, it seems like
he was annoyed with them going through and and watching so much
of his video uh without like adding significant substance to
it. And he also really wanted to get back at these people. He
hated them clearly. >> Sure. So, how much like do you have
a ratio that you think they factor in at? >> Uh, no. I
that's not I haven't really thought about like a percent for
each. I don't think there's one that's like 8020 or anything
like that
>> cuz I would say like maybe there's like a tiny bit of
copyright here, but to me seems pretty transparently obvious.
Like what I would say is that he wanted to hurt these people
in any way he could and he told this story about protecting copyright
ex exclusively because he just didn't want to get called like
a [__] for suing these people over previous drama.
like I don't think that it actually was a positive motivating
factor and that's mostly predicated on one his video announcing
the lawsuits he said he was setting a trap for them explicitly
right
>> okay yeah >> in the video announcing the lawsuits
he also says that the their stated intent is a reason that he
wanted to sue them but when he registered the copyright and was
planning to sue people he couldn't have known what statements
they were going to make so obviously he was planning to sue people
very very much like pre-planning setting it up set up his entire
video under the premise of suing people and he had no idea what
statements they would make. Right. >> Well, couldn't couldn't
it be that he set up this under the premise that he would be
suing them based on their past conduct and then once they had
made the verbal statements that they did that then pushed him
to pull the trigger on the lawsuits? >> I don't think so
because he didn't say that that was a part of any of his pre-planning
going in. And basically, I just think no matter what they said,
they were getting sued if they reacted to the whole video, right?
>> Like, is it possible that he was like 50/50 there and
he got pushed over by what they said? I don't know because what
they said, so what I would say here is what what they said was
they I don't even believe this is true for Denims, but let's
say for Casey Tron, you would say it's Denim's sorry, Casey Trron's
intent or statement of intent to siphon views from him, right?
That pushed him over the edge.
>> Sure. Let's say hypothetically. Yeah. >> Okay.
So, when Ethan Klein debated XQC, he said, "XQC, I think it's
intentful siphoning of views from you when you take my thumbnail,
you barely react to the video. You take my thumbnail, you put
yourself in it, and then you take basically my title, and you
upload that the same day or the next day. I think that's intentionally
siphoning siphoning
So, XQC did that with the content nuke. Do you believe XC was
do you think he has changed his opinion and doesn't think that's
intentionally siphoning views anymore? >> Um, are you saying
that Ethan said this? I don't remember this, but >> he
did say when he was debating XC.
>> So, if he did say this in earnest and it wasn't in the
middle of a debate to make a point, um, then I don't know. He
could just believe that by having that conversation with XQC,
he could convince XQC to not,
I don't know, further react to his content. he could view XQU
as not really a prolific person to be siphoning his content.
Um because I'm not even sure how frequently XUC watches Ethan's
content. Um >> I think XQC was the prototypical maybe the
worst offender for this kind of contact content uh content when
Ethan confronted him about it >> during pro. >> Yeah,
probably. But he I don't believe he was the a principal person
who was consistently reacting to uh Ethan's content. You could
say that XQC and well I I probably I'm not sure if we would include
Asmin Gold, but you could say that XQC was definitely a person
who would do non-reaction streams and stuff like that. but to
Ethan specifically. Um because Ethan would levy the lawsuit unless
we're saying Ethan would levy a lawsuit on other people's behalf,
which I'm not even sure he can do. >> But for this, he
wasn't he he has Ethan has called him a prolific
uh infringer in the past, but it's true that it wasn't over
him XQC infringing upon Ethan's content. He was just sticking
up for other smaller creators that XQC was doing this to. But
for this for the content nuke, Ethan literally watched a clip
from XQC's live stream after he released the nuke. And XQC literally
admitted
that he was not reacting. He was like, I'm watching I'm Am I
reacting to this? No, I'm watching you guys. What about it? And
Ethan watches this and he's like, listen, I respect it. You know,
I I acknowledge he's the king of this this being the copyright
infringement.
So when that clip exists and then a couple of months later he
he releases the video I'm suing these creators and the standard
he outlines for quote unquote like malicious infringement or
whatever like XQC falls under the standard that he outlined in
the video as the stated reason and yet he didn't go after him
>> and he said that going after them would be like would
have a chilling effect on the reaction community. But it's weird
because it's like if you acknowledge this guy is a prolific offender
of infringement, if you acknowledge that even in the video in
question that you're enforcing your IP rights on this content
nuke, you saw a clip of him admitting to just watching and not
reacting or trying to be transformative and you still don't go
after him. How can anybody take it seriously that that is really
your primary intention going into these lawsuits and that you're
actually doing this for the good of the React community and to
preempt the lawsuits from like Sony and Disney that bring down
a standard that's not good.
Um, so the idea would be in my mind that u a couple of things
could be in Ethan's
uh defense in that number one he could believe that people could
reasonably get through to XQC to get them to stop doing this.
Um, he could believe that even he himself could be capable of
speaking to XQC to get through him to not do this. However, there
is one objective undisputable fact is that nobody in the world
is going to get through to Denims and Froggen and what he didn't
get through to XQC is kind of like totally irrelevant because
he did all of the
not to do said we're showing you intentionally siphoning views
all of the things here. So, I don't know why we're >> hypothesizing.
We don't really have to hypothesize reality because we can because
because it's whether or not an individual could be considered
reasonable and could be reasoned with and not whether or not
they created a perfect insulation for them to never take accountability
from outside sources. The only people who could ever in theory
stop Denims and all these other people from doing this type of
react type content would probably be Hassan. That would probably
be it. He's the only person who could do it outside of themselves
>> that would get them to stop doing this. Now, now hold
on. So from Ethan's perspective, so from Ethan's perspective,
and again I want to return to my original statement that I'm
not saying that he's only doing it for the justice of the whatever
stuff, he got mad and upset that these people have been harassing
them or him for quite a while. And he saw that there is no reasonable
way to get through to them. So then he levies this lawsuit where
he believes that they are infringing on copyright infringement.
And so he's like, "Well, I can't get through them. Nobody else
Reasonable is going to get through to them. And I really don't
like these people, so I'm going to do this." >> So again,
in this hypothetical you're doing, it's about them reacting to
his content and not the other things that they've done. >> No.
No. It'd be a mixture of both. Like I said, I'm pretty sure the
lawsuits was a mixture of both. >> Okay. Um, before this,
was it not just both sides reacting to stream clips of each other
engaging in totally reciprocal behavior? >> What are you
talking about? Ethan and
>> No, with Ethan and then Denim, whatever. Weren't they
just like engaging in reciprocal behavior where they'd watch
each other's content and react to it on >> I mean, they
were both react they would each individually react to each other's
content. Yeah. But I would definitely argue that Denims and and
company red do quote unquote less reactions than like Ethan and
stuff does.
>> Uh I would agree with that most of the time, but I don't
know if that's true with regards to the Ethan stuff because they're
specifically getting referenced with the Ethan stuff. >> How
was that a I'm sorry, what what was the point? Regis phrase what
you just said. So I think I would usually agree with you on a
lot of these topics like uh in general Denims plays I think what
is it Reuters or
Al Jazer at the beginning of stream for a long time she's usually
she'll take people's content right but with regards to the Ethan
stuff when she's getting referenced specifically that's maybe
the only time she's actually reacting and talking through stuff
because it's about
>> so I don't know if there's any other stealing Ethan's
content or something. Well, even in the example you gave, it
would only be content that directly references her.
>> I was talking about primarily the content that they
would react to is stuff that would >> like talk about Assan.
They would just go, "Oh, he's lying." And then just play the
video for another like 15 minutes. >> So, you think bad
reactions are things you can like differentiate with?
>> I mean, there has to be a line of bad reactions. And
>> I'm saying like having the wrong opinion like they are
they're stopping and then they're going to give their opinion,
but having like the wrong I think having a wrong opinion is not
a barometer for this. No. >> Okay. So, we feel like Denims
was just doing lazy reactions. I I haven't seen that. I've only
seen the clips that we bring up where she's actually talking
through stuff.
I don't I don't know that it has happened or hasn't happened.
>> Okay. I mean, to be fair, I didn't I I don't think I've
ever watched a full Denim stream. Uh fair enough. But uh I did
watch, you know, fair amounts of I think I watched like 30 minutes
of her reaction to the content nuke and it wasn't much to me.
Um but
yeah, I mean
I don't see why
the argument of yeah, he was motivated
by spite and by a lack of reaction from them couldn't be viable.
uh because in the in the lawsuit that he filed for Denims,
there's multiple points and instances where he
actually
puts like he transcribes what she said in reaction to the content
nuke that he's suing her over and says these arguments are incorrect
and literally like fact checks her within the legal brief that
he filed while he's simultaneously trying to argue that it's
not transformative. like how how how would you reconcile that?
Like you're saying it's not transformative because she didn't
give substantive rebuttals. And when I say substantive, I don't
mean correct. I just mean she disagrees and then expands upon
it even if it's not wellreasoned or like a good way or like a
good disagreement or it's false. Even she does attempt to do
that and manages to do that while she's reacting to it. Ethan
even acknowledges this. Like how can you say it wasn't transformative
in her case when he's literally trying to like insert like like
debate her in his legal brief?
>> Uh because I mean I feel like it'd be more surprising
if you told me this didn't happen. So I don't think Ethan is
like a supremely intelligent person. So I that's number one.
And number two to my knowledge in a lot of legal situations people
just throw everything at the wall. So like this situation where
it's like hey yeah I mean the only thing that would be relevant
for that would maybe be like a defamation thing. Um he's uh obviously
her giving any kind of commentary would be substance against
Ethan's argument regardless of uh the validity as per my understanding.
Somebody can correct me if I'm wrong. Um but the yeah it's like
Ethan is going to view this as like oh yeah no she was lying
about me. I'm going to put that she was lying about me in this
because I don't think he's like a super smart guy and also because
it's a legal thing and he wants to throw everything at the wall.
Yeah. Not only did she not react much, but when she reacted she
lied. >> So wait, wait, wait. So your opinion that basically
if she had that there was some world where Denims reacts to that
whole thing >> and
he doesn't sue her. You think that's a thing that would have
happened
>> if he what? I'm sorry. What? So, so he described this
entire process where he's going to set a trap where he registers
with the Library of Congress to get special statutory damages
so he can sue these people and cause far more financial ruination
than he could otherwise. He sets a trap. He lays this all out,
right? So, it's all a whole bunch of pre-work. You think he would
have done all of that and then when Denims reacts to the whole
thing, you think there's a reaction she could have done where
he doesn't sue her?
>> Yeah, I do.
>> Okay. Why? I mean because I believe that if she actually
like for instance in watching your guys more transformative than
a bunch of people who did this as well, right? Like far more
transformative just
>> Okay, sure. Why do you think that he would not sue her
if she was transformative? And then I want you to tell me whose
reaction was transformative enough that that was the >> Maybe
his son's. But when you go when you're looking at like for instance
how you guys are reacting to this particular video, I don't think
it's I don't think it could be argued
anywhere to any human being alive that this video that you guys
are reacting to, your reaction is not transformative.
I I've I looked I've been watching you guys for like 20 minutes
and I think I've watched like three minutes of the video being
played. Okay, this is one of the most transformative reactions
I've ever seen in my entire life. So, and if Denims did anything
like that with the content nuke, which I believe Hassan did something
similar, wasn't his reaction like 9 hours or something like that?
>> It was like a full group of people,
>> Yeah, it was like a full day this guy did this. I I
feel like there's no shot in hell even you if you want to ask
me a separate question as to whether or not he would have wanted
to give her a lawsuit. But if you ask me if Denim's stream was
the same as his son's where it was a nine hours with like people
coming in and like guest stars or whatever like all that
>> I believe Ethan has basically already said in terms
of transformativity that Denims passes muster because he had
said explicitly he didn't want to chill reactions like Asmin
Gold and XQC. Now what did Asmin Gold and XQC do that
denims didn't? >> What? No, I think I don't think >> he
said he didn't want chill reactions like Asmin Gold and XQC,
he wanted them to be able to keep doing the stuff they >> What
did Denims do that Asmin Gold and XQC didn't?
>> So, from his perspective, I I'm going to have to guess
here. He could be uh because again, we're not making an objectivity
argument here. We're making an argument from Ethan's perspective,
right? And this is the same guy. >> I assume that means
transformativity. Would you agree with that? When he says, "I
don't want to chill reactions like that," he means from a transformation
perspective, right? >> I would assume so. >> He's
talking about >> So, okay. >> So, so I would assume
that in combined with the piece of evidence that was presented
to me by Straighter for the court documents of him inserting
the lies there, it's that probably he has some and I I think
I recall hearing him say something to the effect of like talking
about like the lies that she said. he's probably including like
lies that are told about uh the content or in general in while
reacting to the content. And like I said, I also think he has
a grudge that he wants to make out here. And so he's suing them
also on top of that. So he's saying like, "Yeah, I don't believe
this is transformative content, but part of the reason I don't
believe this is transformative is under a false pretense that
lies makes it less transformative
and I don't like these people." And now he doesn't want to chill
this type of uh content to Asmin Golden XQC. Well, he doesn't
believe it's gonna necessarily chill it as much because they
don't lie as much or they don't uh do these uh uh things that
that Denims and Froggen and uh Caseyron does. >> Okay.
So when Pisco said that Ethan was wrong and gave these exact
reasons, right, and then Ethan called him a [__]
do you think it not kind of proves out that he's heard the argument
back in the other direction that like it is as more transformative?
>> commented on Pisco's coverage?
>> Do you think it's not like you think after he's received
like backlash that says, "Hey, that's not how this works." >> Has
he tried to update the lawsuit? Has he admitted he was wrong
on this? or has he called the people who pointed out that he
was wrong morons? >> No, that's perfectly in line with
my thought that he's just not a very smart
>> Okay. Do we say that people get to do immoral actions
or or do things for the wrong reasons because they're just dumb?
Like this is the Trump um he actually >> I never I never
said >> I don't think this is like a particularly immoral
thing. Um, I I don't. But even if I were to accept that it was
Even if I were to accept this is one of the worst things ever
done, what the argument is is whether or not he could have, and
this is the idea, he could have done this with the idea of him
wanting to protect copyright and him not liking these people
in mind. And I I think that's true. any evidence to show >> what
you're arguing here is basically that his bias totally clouded
his
>> and he couldn't identify that Denims had a far more
transformative reaction than XQC and so even though he said XQC's
standard XQC's react which was a good enough standard that he
didn't want to sue him that he didn't want to chill that he didn't
even want to chill it not that he didn't even want to sue he
didn't want to chill XQC's reaction right so he focuses in on
the statements made which is the intent to siphon views so that
he doesn't chill XQC's reaction which is a okay. He maybe you
could argue he was so biased that he couldn't identify that Denim's
reaction was better than XQC's or more transformer. >> I
don't think I don't think it's like he's so biased. I just also
I just don't think he's really smart. >> Okay, but I think
he's notic
on a counter, right? XQC added like 20 minutes to the run time.
>> Hold on. My Can you guys still hear me? My computer
just fell asleep.
uh yeah, I mean you can you could say that he only added 20 minutes
to
the runtime. But again, I can go back to my previous argument,
which is that he doesn't view XQC as like a significant threat
to
uh um Ethan's content. For instance, in an example where I actually,
let's say I me personally, meen
or denim. >> Let me give you a hypothetical.
Let's say me personally, I have um a big streamer like XQC every
once in a while watching some of my content and not being very
transformative of it. Um I'm not going to be nearly as upset
about that as I might be a group of people who I feel are specifically
and intentionally targeting my content and have been doing so
for months. And especially if these people are just like being
malicious and I feel like they're lying about me and stuff like
that. This is I feel like this is a very human reaction to that
kind of a situation and especially if you enter the context that
XQC is willing to open a dialogue with Ethan so he's at least
able to reason with this human being but these other >> offered
to go on his he didn't let it >> Um
I don't believe I don't I don't know really how you can say some
of the things that you did in this conversation and say in earnest
that that conversation would have been in good faith. Do you
really feel like that conversation would have been a good faith
dialogue? >> In terms of the good faith conversation, Ethan
was her and I believe was >> who invited her on and then
she took him up on the offer and then he retracted
>> So Ethan was under the the belief that she could have
had a good faith there was a good faith discussion or that if
it was bad faith that he could embarrass her, but then when she
actually stepped up to the plate to speak to him, he wouldn't
do it. Assuming what you're saying uh is accurate, I would just
assume he was posturing more than anything. I would assume he's
like, "Oh, yeah." I don't think How do you reconcile that with
like Denims is the one that's not willing to have an open dialogue
if like >> I don't think either one of them are
>> What do you think about the fact that Ethan has based
on legal counsel had to retract defamatory statements multiple
times. Um, then that's the I don't know. He's trying to keep
himself secure.
Liar on the internet. I'm saying he's lying here when he has
totally inconsistent reasoning. And I feel like you've come in
and gone. We should give him the benefit of the doubt. I just
feel like really he like actually lies a lot on the internet.
>> Like I feel like he's has an established reputation
as a liar on the internet.
>> Okay. Well, I'm just talking about whether or not his
motives even
>> Well, no. You're you're trying to establish a motive
for that that I don't think you can establish. I don't think
you have enough evidence to say that he doesn't care about copyright.
I I don't What have I said that is totally improbable or impossible?
I feel like everything that I've said for a not particularly
intelligent guy who I've already admitted has a vendetta against
these people can come to the conclusion that yeah, you know what,
I'm doing the right thing. I hold >> he doesn't care about
like fair use or the protection of the React community. I wouldn't
say he doesn't if I said he doesn't care about commentary. Oh,
>> Yeah, I was about to say that's not he doesn't care
about fair use or like >> basically his his argument is
I'm doing this to protect the commentary community from like
a big lawsuit. Um, one that can't happen because that's like
a totally thing. He can't set a precedent for anything that he's
claimed. And two, he has actually made it obvious that now any
creator can do the same thing in retrospect
whenever they want. Right? So if you for example really were
reacting to Asan content and he didn't like that because you've
criticized him in the past he is a vendetta against you he could
retroactively register his stream with the Library of Congress
and sue you and if you did react to his stuff and if it wasn't
transformative enough which by the way the bar is way above what
Denims or XQC or 90 90% of people who reacted to it did he would
just win and he would be able to enforce statutory damages on
you that you probably wouldn't be able to pay.
That's obviously like an unfair thing that would happen, right?
Given the meadow that you he participates in, you participate
in,
>> How does that do how does that do away with my point?
>> Um, wait, you wait, you're sorry. So, I said obviously
it's not about him caring about copyright. I said it's more about
him um trying to protect protect the React community, which he's
lying about. I think I I don't believe that copyright goes into
his motives, but I think his overall thing, his stated opinion
is just factually incorrect. We'd agree on that, right? His stated
opinion for why he did this, that he's trying to protect the
react community, that's obviously >> I I believe that he
if you want to ask, is it objectively correct or can I reason
out through his motives? >> Well, I I don't want to do
the subjective like mind readading thing cuz you're going to
read positive intention into him at all times. >> Oh, well
then, yeah, but everything that every single React streamer does
is like what? If we're talking about from an objective standpoint,
why the are we even criticizing anybody? You guys aren't going
to do anything. >> Wait, but that doesn't that cut again?
Doesn't that work in our favor though to to show that that's
the copyright thing is literally not really a factor then because
if every single streamer is engaging in this then to go after
these specific people to settle other scores unrelated to the
infringement especially when gets like 80 viewers Casey Trron
gets IDK how many viewers Denims gets the most out of out of
all of them if like there's this is rampant and he goes after
them wouldn't that suggest that the primary motive is because
of personal vendettas and not to do with copyright infringement.
>> Wait, which one are we talking about? Are we talking
about personal motives or are we talking about whether or not
there's objectivity behind it? Because JTO just said a second
ago, I want to scratch the subjective mind reading. Are we not
reading this, okay? In terms of ratio, if his if his primary
concern was copyright and his views being siphoned, he would
go after the people siphoning far more views, right?
>> No, you that assumes a reasonable rational person. I
don't think Ethan is a particular just to be clear. I think >> we're
going to assume Ethan's rational for the rest of the conversation
because if I just assume Ethan is
like at all times and I can explain all of his issues away by
being a then it's like not even an interesting conversation.
You can literally say >> you can say it's not an interesting
conversation but
girl that down syndrome girl. Well, he's kind of man. He didn't
have bad intentions. It's like totally pointless to have that
conversation, right? >> It's not totally pointless cuz
that's how we get to material reality. This is a guy who has
a history of doing things that are not particularly intelligent,
doing something that's not particularly intelligent. I I if you
don't if you don't know how to read the world, I don't know what
to tell you. Like, yes, I I feel like these people probably,
you know, there's there's actually a case that they might have
convicted. >> I think I think you have to criticize the
lawsuit on the fact that Ethan doesn't have Ethan does not have
the agency. He does not have he needs a guardian. He can't sue
people.
with actual agency cuz he's too stupid to take responsibility
for his actions. >> No, it's that when looking at this
situ everything that I described fits with somebody who's not
particularly intelligent but is not totally
okay. It is that a guy he has a vendetta against these people,
right? He sees that they haven't been reacting as much as he
would like. Again, what Strader brought up is perfectly in line
with this idea. Oh, they're lying about me, so that means that
it's less fair use. this is perfectly in line with a guy who's
not particularly intelligent. And then so he's like, "Yeah, you
know what? They're lying about me. They said a bad bunch of bad
stuff and I got a vendetta against these people. So I'm going
to start a lawsuit against these people and they won't listen
to me. I can't I can't reason with these people." >> Intelligence
to me is a red herring in this context because he's also obscenely
wealthy and any lawyer that he would have consulted would have
told him if he listened to them. Uh yeah, like somebody something somebody
can lie and they can still be transformative and that doesn't
constitute infringement. So you probably shouldn't put that in
there. So he can be stupid, but like he's not the one who actually
wrote the legal brief, he like directed his lawyer to [__]
do it. >> Absolutely. So maybe we can get Pisco's opinion
on this, but based on my limited knowledge and I speaking with
other lawyers and directly interacting with a legal case extremely
recently, they will throw everything at the wall. I just interacted
with a legal case literally three weeks ago where they were throwing
literally everything at the wall that was had nothing to do with
the case whatsoever. So I imagine
>> Pisco like spurred for out about it. Pisco like got
>> Okay. Yeah, I understand. Pisco spur did Pisco spur
out
spurred about the case. >> No, no, no, no. Because I want
to separate something. Did he spur the out because it's very
obviously not relevant to the material facts or did he spur the
out because okay well then yeah I would agree with that. However
that's >> they argued that
not involved in the lawsuit is like the grand of Palestine. >> Do
do lawyers throw the book at people when they try and sue them?
Do they throw everything that they can? >> They throw relevant
arguments in and I don't think there's any
Okay. So I I wish I could leak a recent legal thing that I went
through. This is not true. I went through a recent legal case
with somebody very very recently read all of these briefs with
lawyers that I promise are probably better than what either any
of the parties including Ethan had. And these lawyers said everything.
Okay? They sent like emails talking about them going to hardware
stores and said like these people are clearly like malicious
actors. completely irrelevant because you just throw everything
at the person when you're and you just hope whatever sticks.
And >> so there's nothing that could have been put into
the legal brief that could make you question or doubt the primary
intentions of Ethan,
>> no matter how absurd or like how much the arguments
are like they seem to be. OB if if you in if you include infinite
absurdity obviously if he like put like nudes of denims in there
completely unnecessarily. Yeah, I would say that's ridiculous.
But th this specifically that in the context of a uh fair use
argument that a dude who is particularly not intelligent was
like, "Oh yeah, here here lawyer here are some examples of this
person lying during their reaction." Like I could 100% see Ethan
sitting there going like, "Oh yeah, she didn't react to my content
at all." And actually, you know what? Here's a better point.
When she reacted, she also lied.
>> And yeah, put that in there. I could 100. You don't
think that's something that you would do? >> I mean, I
>> No, I could absolutely see him doing it. I think he
did direct his lawyer because again if you listen to his lawyer
they would have said that actually doesn't transformation doesn't
hinge on like how honest the person is being in their commentary
but given his ego and arrogance I can see that he told them yeah
put it in there anyway but then I only brought that up to say
that that speaks to me his what his primary intentions are which
is to launder in all of his beef and grievances with these people
into the legal briefs as a way to dunk on them. And that to me
signals that like what he primarily cares about is just embarrassing
them and making life hell for them and not actually the infringement
or any harm that he that came from their infringement allegedly
or anything about protecting the React community from a lawsuit
from Sony or Disney, which is literally what he said. >> Okay,
I understand you can have that takeaway. The way that I take
this away is it's just standard legal throwing everything that
you can at your person, the other person. And this doesn't even
feel like it's that crazy. I feel like when you start getting
like I I truly wish I could show you guys this legal case that
was >> really it was really significant and had really
big lawyers, super big lawyers and the like some of the best
in the country and they just threw >> you think it was
relevant or do you think a lawyer would add something to say
that Hassan is like the grand muy
>> when it's like Hassan's not a party of the case and
Hassan's not being sued for
>> Sorry, what what specifically isn't relevant? like the
Hassan is like the Grand Muy of Palestine who met with him. >> I
don't I don't know. I would need to see the context. >> Okay.
And then do you think it's possible to have like an actual argument
on this when we don't treat Ethan like a reasonable person? Do
you think there's like any way cuz then it's just basically having
like an emotional argument, right? >> Like if we don't
treat Ethan like a remotely reasonable person when we just say
he's like then we don't actually we can't analyze his logical
lens. So basically, you said multiple points in this. How are
you? >> There's just no reason we should have the conversation
because if I try to hold him logically accountable for his actions
and I say like given this progression of facts, there's clearly
no way that this happens, right? You're like, well, actually,
I think a person could think that anyway, then it's like, okay,
I just then we're having like an emotional argument. >> No,
because the problem is you're throwing the baby out with a bathwater.
You're saying that because I previously called him in and some
of the things that I did, uh, that means that he is so
that this guy needs a guardian. That's ridiculous. You can't
just go from 0 to 100. I think Ethan isn't a particularly intelligent
individual and he has a vendetta. And I think with those two
pieces of information, all of his conduct makes sense. What of
his conduct, if we don't think he's a smart person, we actually
think he's a bit dumb. Let's say that he's actually a dumb person.
and he has a vendetta. How does what bit of his conduct doesn't
make sense? >> Most dumb people are incapable of being
like rational actors. >> Like do you think they don't act
in their own self? >> Specific moments they can be rational.
>> Okay. But moment it's like a legal case where you go
and talk to talk to them and talk through the case you want to
present before you present it. Right. >> This isn't like
this isn't like a momentary lapse. This is like would have been
over like days or possibly weeks that he would have gone to to
submit this lawsuit. Right. It's not like a It's not like a decision.
>> I don't I don't What is >> in fact because of
the registering of the copyright, we know in fact that it was
months that he planned these lawsuits for
>> so I'm saying that we have to treat him like a reasonable
person. We can't treat him like an illogical or else it's pointless
to have the conversation because anything he does can be explained
away by the fact that he's an
>> So he wait really quick. He registered the copyright
for the content nuke back in January of this year. Then after
they all reacted to it, he also registered another piece of content
that Denims reacted to right before, which was the H3 podcast
episode that was like celebrating the debut of the content nuke.
And he registered that with the Library of Congress right before
he launched the lawsuit against her as >> I don't know
what that has to do with anything. What was your point? that
he probably had a good idea that her original reaction to the
content nuke was transformative and he registered a different
stream so that he could still sue her >> because it wasn't
about the content nuke actually. He just wanted to sue Denims.
>> So basically there was nothing there was no reaction
that she could have done that would have that would have saved
her from not being hit with a lawsuit over copyright infringement.
So basically when actually this is a good point just really >> well
I'm going to make an argument real quick and then you can hear
the whole argument and then tell me. So basically Ethan registers
this content nuke. He for some reason watches Denim's reaction
and goes
and then after her reaction registers a different piece of content
which is the stream from earlier that day where she got up and
walked away. Right. To me, that is the perfect indication that
he knows that it's transformative or it's at least on the line
because he wants to sue Denims. He registers a new piece of content
which is the stream from that day. So, he can still sue Denims
and guarantee some kind of damages against her. Do you think
that's do you think that's implausible? >> So,
why would he sue another stream from >> like months later
after registered the original ones? >> Why would he like
register a new stream months later?
I mean, there's multiple reasons he could want to sue her for
more money because she he believes that there's multiple different
instances that would strengthen his case to be able to present
in court against her to be able to also get higher amounts of
damages for. He could believe that that specific instance was
a particularly greater uh uh particularly greater uh display
of a lack of reaction and uh theft of content. Um, like, yeah,
I don't know why you're just saying that that's not possible.
Why? Why are either one of those theories not possible? >> No,
they're definitely possible. But if he could just sue them for
the first he could just sue her for the first case, right? If
he was only suing people who actually infringe on his copyright
for the first case, and that's the entire purpose, then why did
he why did he register that second thing? Or why did he have
to why is he still her for the >> He has multiple different
instances of her infringing on his copyright that would strengthen
his case. You're just you're literally asking me why would I
in during a lawsuit where I'm trying to make an argument that
this person is a prolific copyright infringer. Why would I not
get multiple instances of them engaging in copyright infringement?
>> Oh, wait. >> Because I because I want to strengthen
my video >> that Ethan said Oh, did Ethan say he was limiting
the scope just to his prepared com content, not his streams?
That's why he wasn't suing anybody who reacted to the H3 streams?
No, I'm just preventing I'm just presenting a a very clear line
of logic that I feel like is super plausible and super intuitive
for why he could have done this. If you have something that that
shoots that down, I'd like to hear
>> Well, apparently he said that he was only going to sue
for prepared content for people reacting to his prepared scripted
content. I don't see that here.
>> the other thing to me, what do you think of this? if
they are infringing upon his copyright and this really is about
being primarily upset over that and not primarily about his personal
dislike or the his beef with them. Why didn't he use any of the
DMCA tools or send a cease and desist letter before launching
the lawsuits? >> Uh maybe because he wanted to
uh directly
have these people get like a monetary punishment for doing this
in the hopes that they would never do it again. they're broke.
They don't have the what monetary punishment could he extract
from them when they don't have money. That's why Casey Tron had
to settle. And then her apology was like only a little bit about
was about saying, "I'm sorry about infringing upon copyright."
And then it's like, "I'm sorry to the clients. I'm sorry about
anti-semitism and leftist spaces. I'm sorry for the comments
I made about Asmin Gold's mom." like just get basically financially
coercing her to make all of to extract all of these apologies
from her that are completely unrelated to the stated intent for
this lawsuit which is copyright infringement and protecting the
reaction community >> because I mean them being broke
doesn't change the fact he would want to hurt them monetarily.
It would in fact it would strengthen the idea that he would want
to hurt them monetarily because if they're broke then they won't
be able to keep up this behavior. We agree that he wanted to
hurt them monetarily. We're saying that's primary and and massive
motivation way more than anything else.
>> He would be suing other people. >> Yeah. Because
that speak to me the fact that like he he is suing them even
though he knows that he's going to lose money in this entire
process. It wasn't just that like trying to deter and like uh
change the what is it? Prevent a lawsuit from Sony or Disney
to protect the little guy and not kill the reaction community.
Okay. if that's really your motive or whatever, then you wouldn't
just be maximizing the behavior around this lawsuit to curtail
their individual infringement. You would be thinking like, how
do I curtail their behavior as well as anybody else who reacts
like them? Because regardless of what his like intentions are,
you know, if if his complaint against uh Denims and Froggen goes
the distance, like it actually goes to trial,
>> he would um if he's actually sticking true to his principles,
and this is about uh you know, limiting the argument to I want
to go after reactors that do this intentional stated malice thing
as an additional factor that should make something not fair use.
Right? Then it if like if he wasn't doing that then that this
lawsuit is no different than any other lawsuit as far as going
after reaction streamers cuz you could still chill the entire
community
cuz it could set a devastating precedent if he doesn't make it
that narrow. Yeah.
>> I mean he's already
know whether or not it it would. I imagine you already the React
community,
>> No. that he's like presented. Yeah, sure. XQC's reactions
aren't offensive. The critical commentary. So, in terms of like
like chilling commentary or chilling critical commentary, he
has now revealed a method that very few people were aware of
where you can sue and skip actual damages. Usually the way copyright
works is you you sue for actual damages, the views that were
siphoned away, right? But in this case, he's suing for statutory
damages. And he's now revealed it like he's revealed a way to
most people where they can sue for statutory damages and just
crush small commentary channels who are critical of their stuff.
>> I I don't blame him for doing this. I think if you really
wanted to do this and if you were like a like a large channel,
I'm pretty sure you could figure out how to do this pretty easily.
I don't think this was like a njutsu
secret hand signign trick that 101 secret facts for how to sue
another person. I don't it didn't seem like it was a particularly
complicated method that this dude went through to do this. >> I
think I think essentially nobody knew about it. I do not believe
this has been done through YouTube yet.
The reason this was made this was made and used most extensively
by the RAIAA to go after people who downloaded music. So if you
torrented like three songs, they could basically bankrupt you,
right? That's why this law that's why this legislation exists.
>> That's what Ethan Klein's doing. He's like the RAIA
trying to bankrupt people who stole a couple songs.
And to me it's almost mutually exclusive because if I grant you
Rei that he is directing his lawyers to just throw at the wall
to see what sticks as far as like building a strong legal case
against them to make their, you know, to make it maximally hurtful
to them financially, socially, etc. Then that goal is almost
mutually exclusive with fighting to establish a fair use precedent.
That's not going to chill the reaction community because in the
course of these lawyers throwing at the wall to see what sticks,
they are inevitably going to make they're they're going to create
a standard that could potentially chill the reaction community.
So, the fact that he decided to go that route in the lawsuits
to me tells me that he is completely fine with creating a devastating
precedent if it actually went to like a trial and uh he like
went all the way. >> That's not true. his 100% without
question. I know this for an absolute fact. He he is assuming
that they all settle. He's assuming they all buckle.
>> So then it's not for an absolute fact. >> It's
not about establishing a fair president. Then then that invalidates
the claim to it. No, it doesn't because No, it doesn't. Because
then the consequence of that would be that people, us individual
human beings can look at the social consequence of that where
it's like, oh, okay, that if we do this type of thing, some people
can clap back. I should be more careful about doing this type
of malicious content sniping. I shouldn't do this into the future.
You don't have to have a court precedent for for the established
like social precedent of, yeah, no, I shouldn't be going out
here and saying, I'm just going to steal other people's No, stop
stop this irrelevant conversation. Sorry, you have to tell me
how you know for 100% fact that this is the case. Cuz then if
we're going to
entirely based entirely on his posture and his action and his
willingness to be able to have these people settled
dangerous this guy dangerous you can't predict his actions. He
can't say >> I absolutely can't predict. So I reject your
narrative that is totally non
>> Wait, your problem is you your mind works in a one and
a person. You said he was non autonomous. You are the person
who's been arguing he's not reasonable mind works.
>> Jtock, let me ask you a simple question. Can people
be dumb but not totally incapable and >> yes or no? >> But
do you understand? You just you just cart blanch to be as as
subjective as you could possibly be and never argue anything.
Just anytime you want you go, well, he's dumb in this case but
not in another case. >> That's what you're doing right
now. Absolutely. That's what you're doing. >> Absolutely
not. No, you need to provide me an instance where he was so incredibly
what he did is only explainable by a total and complete that
needs a guardian. So far you have not done that. Not even close.
>> He went to file a copyright case and then he presented
a video where he said this is my reason for filing a copyright
case. He would have talked to the copyright lawyer. He would
have obviously said this is why I want to file it. The copyright
lawyer would have said what? Oh yeah that's totally fine and
we can totally do that. Or they have said well you could say
that but technically under the law that doesn't work. Do you
think the copyright lawyer would have said, "Hey, this is how
the law works." Or do you think the copyright lawyer would have
said, "You're totally correct." >> I don't think it's well
established whether or not any of this is as fair use under copy.
Pretty well established.
You say, "I'm going to set a precedent based on stated uh malicious
intent." That that is not something that can happen in copyright
claims. That is not >> sure that it's not stated malicious
intent. The lawyer probably told them that, but then you know
what the lawyer probably told them? I don't know. But then why
did he go and say that he wanted to set a precedent around how
that is the problem with copyright infringement? Like he wanted
to set a precedent where stated malicious intent isn't allowed
to happen. But he didn't want to kill anybody else. That's what
he said probably because he believed that it was >> that
is not possible.
>> So yeah, probably
his lawyer would not have his lawyer probably wouldn't have said
that. His lawyer would have said that like a state of malicious
intent isn't relevant to this particular issue, right? But this
person might have committed actual copyright infringement. That
seems like they might have. We can run this in court. And then
he would be like, "Yeah, you know what? Let's run this in court
and throw this at the wall." And then he could say that that
was his intent for pushing this forward. Especially if you put
it in conjunction with the idea that he's expecting these people
to settle, which I fully expect. I don't think in any way, shape,
or form Ethan Klein thought all of these broke
be able to go for him in court. >> So lying is okay because
he expects them to set. >> It's not lying. Where's the
lie?
that it was primarily about protecting the react community. >> He
can believe that it's primarily about protecting the react community.
If do you want to talk about whether or not it will lead to that?
That's a separate >> That they will not set the president.
But if he really believes the president can be set, right? Then
why would why would he want them to settle if he could set the
precedent? >> What do you the president can be set without
even the trial in the first place? If he expects them to settle
and to back the out then the president
HE'S NOT TRYING TO SET NECESSARILY a legal LEGAL PRECEDENT. HE'S
JUST TRYING TO GET THESE PEOPLE TO BACK OUT. IF HE WAS TRYING
TO SET A LEGAL LEGAL PRECEDENT, why even let any of them back
out? WHY LET ANY OF WELL, NO, NO, NO. ANSWER THIS. If he's trying
to No, no, no. I want you to answer this qu I want you to answer
this question. If he is definitely trying to set a legal precedent,
why would he let any of them back out ever? >> Um because
Casey Tron is a poor like hillbilly and Dennis is going to fight
until the end. >> He said he said it multiple times. He
doesn't care. Oh, also because hold on, hold on. Why would he
My answer is obvious. Sorry. Sorry, but you're right. My answer
is obvious. Copyright isn't actually his concern. His concern
is hurting these people, humiliating them. >> No. Okay.
So, you're No, no, no. Because you made the argument.
>> Let's go. >> No. No. No. You made the argument
that he this is this was a motive for his primary concern. I
never made that argument. I never made the argument that yes,
he clearly cared about a legal president. My argument was that
he cared about a president in general.
>> I never said that he cared about getting a law put into
the book. >> His stated reason for doing this is to set
a legal precedent against explicitly saying you have a malicious
intent
>> Did he say that? Can you I maybe he said that. Okay.
Where is that? Where is the >> video about this?
a video about this. >> Yeah. Yeah. >> Yeah. I'm I'm
curious. >> It's at the very beginning. Hold on.
>> here I sent I sent it to to just >> this video.
>> Hi there. My name >> Wait, how far do we have
to go in >> and my favorite >> at the very beginning
>> is spending hundreds of thousands of dollars on lawyers
today. I invite you into my home to share my favorite pastime
with you. Join me in creating generational wealth for my attorney.
Let
>> That's That's about copyright, right? to tell you guys
a story about a >> that's definitely not a year and a half
>> It's a big conversation called ReactGate.
ReactGate was a debate going on in the streaming community about
what constituted fair use. People like Hassan XQC and many of
the large Twitch streamers would watch other creators entire
video on their stream. They would rarely add sufficient commentary
or even pause the video to speak. Most egregious
>> It'd be so It'd be such a big play from XQC to do precisely
this to Ethan over this video specifically. They would re-upload
the entire VOD to YouTube with the same thumbnail, the same title,
so that they could traffic from the original video. Here's what
Lemino had to say about this phenomenon. I don't >> Uh,
so the exact thing that he complained about before, I think we've
all identified that denims in them did >> reacting to my
videos, but I do mind when they play the entire >> uh XQC
did the entirety of my video. A facecam in the corner with the
occasional interruption does nothing to address that issue. My
video is still being played from beginning to end in someone
else's stream or video. It's neither ethical nor necessary to
feature >> Oh, do we need to go to this time stamp instead
or >> of someone else's work or, you know, they could do
the bare minimum and ask for permission, something that none
of the major reaction channels have ever done when they've streamed
or reuploaded my videos. But to answer your question, no, I I
don't want people to stream or re-upload the entirety of my videos.
Now, understandably, this made a lot of people angry because
why should these content thieves essentially get more views than
the author of the video, which in a lot of cases was happening.
I mean, people don't like injustice, and this just we all see
this and no, it's not right. This debate culminated when XQC,
one of the prime suspects, called in to my show to debate me,
in which case, I'm sad to report that I was uh terribly owned.
So, in that regard, do you care at all about like IP or copyright
or like the fact that it's illegal? Does that matter if that
it might be illegal? Uh does that matter to you? Uh no, >> it
doesn't matter. >> Is your stream your stream like on Discord
isn't moving for me?
>> Oh,
wait. And is it broken for both of you guys? >> I It just
wasn't moving. It just showed like uh Ethan's face.
>> It wasn't doing anything.
>> What about now? >> Okay, now it's good, I think.
>> Watch full screen can do the warmth, then watch your
then watch your planned content for a week. >> Do a week
of no reaction content and see how many views you get. >> Oh,
okay. Sure. I mean, that's content, man. It's original content.
At least the ultimate debate, bro. He hit him with the worm.
>> Oh, why didn't I think of that first? I >> I do
love that the worm. Okay, XQC actually won this debate because
the worm led to XQC doing all of the things that Ethan just said
were bad to the content nuke and he didn't get sued. So, WXQC.
The worm actually totally wormed into his brain. >> But
he is not the one I'm suing. Despite my criticism, he's not a
malicious infringer. But the ones I am suing, you'll see, are
much, much worse. Now, ironically, after this debate and in the
wake of this large conversation, the problem seems to have only
gotten worse.
I was referencing earlier
>> goes along with what >> the motive I was referencing
earlier. He believes that Xuc is not a malicious infringer. I.e.
he is somebody who can be reasoned with. I.e. he is somebody
that can be uh uh talked to. He's not trying to just steal people's
content. That's not his intent. >> This is
pull up.
>> Yeah. bring I I I linked to you where he literally watches
him react to this very piece of content that he is suing them
for infringement. >> And then here is more commentary uh
from >> Let's see how long he can go without offering any
commentary or analysis on this Hamas hype video.
>> This was a very good edit.
>> I like this part. >> That dumb cartoon crunching.
>> Yeah. Is that the Is that >> Did they put a Did
they put a timer here just to show how long it takes XQC to say
anything? Like further mogging Ethan as he watches this. That's
>> I invented this rea
this type of reactor. Literally, >> you are a
trends setter, a path blazer, my friend. >> Dude, this
is this is actual Sneo level in the chair. You're trying to make
a point about copyright infringement. You're watching this guy
infringe and go, I invented this kind of infringement. As exec
laughs and says, I invented the exact thing Ethan's complaining
about here. >> A fine watched path blade. You walked down
that you blaze down that path with the sickest watch. >> I
mean, I think Mr. Sher is an excuse originated thing, too. He's
really >> He's pretty I will say he is pretty um >> I
don't know if that's true. Well,
>> I'm pretty sure it's a Hassan pick. I I remember when
that was OG OG and I'm pretty sure it was Hassan. >> I
think they say Mr. Chair on XQC's stream, but I think it is a
a an XQC. Sorry, an Hassan original. I think it's they say it
on XQC's stream because it was a Hassan thing.
>> Oh, yes. Yes. >> Yeah. I don't even know where
we're going here, but I do believe that when he debated XQC,
he explicitly says,
um, I think this is maliciously like, you're maliciously siphoning
views. You're intentionally siphoning views. The exact same thing
they stated they were doing because of how he does it. Hold on
a second. >> This is more >> when he's talking to
XQC.
>> Why is it >> Okay. Well, wouldn't that wouldn't
that pertain still to the idea that he can have a dialogue with
these people that's at least he feels like is somewhat
>> No, because they infringed upon the content nuke >> because
he did the same thing.
He can have a dialogue with them. So, it's I I'm sorry. Hold
on. Is this Is this Hold on. Can I just say this?
>> And then they keep Are they somebody that you can have
a dialogue with?
>> What do you think? You've asked them to >> you've
Well, it's non-consensual taking non-conensual taking of this
is not at all comparable to like a violent very obviously problematic
like you know let's not do the no I'm just going to do one for
one why just let me let me say I started speaking and you just
spoke up you've asked them to stop stealing your content they
continue to steal your
>> is that proof that they are capable of a
>> okay so I'm going to say I'm going to ask the question
that I started that you interrupted me. Okay. So for Ethan, okay,
he sees he can see XQC as a malicious or even in a situation,
a particular situation, a malicious content thief in a moment.
But by the mere fact that he's able to have what he considers
to be a mutually respective dialogue, he refuses to engage in
any kind of legal action because he believes that he can put
social pressure or use some kind of other means to be able to
influence him out of it.
>> Why not? Why is that? Hold on. Why is that not >> in
your mind that would be why? Please tell me why you think he
thinks that. >> Because because he hasn't sued him. >> He
has the little evidence that it doesn't work. He has the opposing
evidence that he asked him to stop and then XQC said you I'm
doing the worm. Get loser. I'm stealing all of your videos. I'm
stealing the content nuke. Suck my >> Has he stole all
of his videos?
How's that PROOF OF A DIALOGUE? PLEASE. HE LITERALLY CAN TALK
to him. He literally can talk to him and have a conver. I don't
understand how you don't realize how this works. You understand?
So, for instance, I actually want to hear from this. I have a
kind of a comparable thing inside of my chat room. It's called
Discord or ban. Okay? If you're saying stupid in inside of my
chat room, I will invite you on to Discord and you can say pretty
much anything that is not
ban you. Do you think that that makes me the same as Ethan? Oh,
well, you know what? He has a dialogue. Well, what does that
mean? He has to get kicked. That makes no sense. You are willing
to have a dialogue with me. Even if I think you're a
and you're doing something horrible, you're willing to have a
dialogue with me. So, you could stay. Is am I just totally for
doing that? >> No, but you said, okay, wait, wait. I think
you changed the goal. You should go because you went from saying,
"No, you went from saying
yes. The answer is yes, the answer is yes." Hold on. The answer
is actually yes, you are for doing that. you are the Chinese
faction that got dominated and taken over by the Mongols cuz
you're like, "Well, we can negotiate with them." It's like every
time we negotiate with them, they say, "Give us everything and
you and so you keep negotiating with them as they say, give me
everything. I'm going to your women and your men and then then
that's how we
did is he raped Ethan." >> Yes. Yes. Yes. That is actually
what it is. That's actually what's happening
>> No, I just It's a very low stake situ It's a very low
stake situation.
engage in a dialogue with them and then I can explain to me what
the purpose of a dialogue is. >> Can you explain to me
what the purpose of the purpose of a dialogue is to show that
the individual has some there is some attempt or good faith from
the other individual to be able to engage in a conversation about
the the material facts or the morality of whatever they're doing.
And even at the very least, if they don't take away your opinion
out of the situation, then the other person can be like socially
uh uh ostracized or uh you could be it's put on record. You're
putting somebody on the record for their positions and then the
the court of social opinion or whatever can do its work. >> Yes.
Literally came in just real quick. Sorry. Sorry. Xuc came in.
He said, "I'm going to keep doing this. you. I have my house
on your I have your house on my wrist. Get you loser. Suck my
French. And then he left and that he kept stealing content from
people. And then he stole the content nuke. So what part of that
dialogue shows he's able to engage in good faith dialogue because
nothing actually got resolved
in general. I own you, you stupid and then he went and kept stealing
stuff. >> Like this is again this is a one to one analogy
for how I do my Discord. I have several conservative MAGA people
inside of my chat room. But because every time they say something
bad I or something I disagree with, I can drag them on. >> They
came on and said the hard R instead of engaging at all. Would
you keep inviting them to say at least they have a at least they
have a dialogue?
>> I it sorry XC. >> I'm literally forced to ban
them if they say the hard R. I can't do anything >> Sorry.
Imagine it wasn't a toss. They just they just yell lemon the
whole time. There's no nothing useful. There's no good dialogue
to happen. >> That's not a proper analogy. They're actually
having a conversation and they're giving arguments back and forth.
They It just resolved in them not both saying I die. >> I
just want to remind everybody that this was the This was the
argument. This was the argument. W dialogue. >> That was
the W dialogue. Let's go. >> That was the totality of the
argument. The entire argument was >> No, he had he had
some good arguments, but he was too tired cuz he stayed up for
like 36 hours before he went and had this debate. So, he literally
couldn't talk and then he did the worm. He got
and then did the worm. Do you think XQC could and Ethan could
have a dialogue if they wanted to like today or tomorrow? >> Possibly.
Yeah. But I think I think to do with how reasonable XQC is and
way more to do with how big he is of a
>> Let's introduce AAM's. Let's roll. You have barely substantiated
anything in this conversation. You've been reaching
insane reads for what is
that I've said. Nothing that insane.
>> Disagree. disagree, but >> hey, can you give me
some of the insane things I said? >> Sure, but after I
finish my point, which is let's introduce AAM's razor. Is it
more realistic that that's why he's not going after XQC or is
it that he's not going after XQC because he needed to manufacture
public uh support for these lawsuits that would probably be viewed
un disfavorably given that now he's he's now the big guy going
after the little guy. And so instead of he doesn't want to make
enemies out of XQC and Asmin Gold because he needs them on his
side to go after these people.
>> No, I No, I do not believe I'm not even sure Ethan Klein
is capable of looking that far into the future. No, >> absolutely.
Well, the ridiculous thing that I thought that you said that
was probably a [__] reach, which is that even though
Ethan said his stated motive was to not kill the React community
and to save them from a potential lawsuit from Sony or Disney
that could set a devastating precedent, he's going to sue these
creators to set a better legal precedent. And then when you said,
"Oh, well, he wasn't actually talking about legal precedent.
He was talking about a social precedent by punishing these individual
people financially and socially as much as he could even though
he was talking about a legal precedent. That was the most ridiculous
thing that he said. >> So, okay. Well, you guys have yet
to substantiate him saying, "Yeah, no, this is a legal thing.
I do not care if they all settle. I want a legal thing. I want
it to be legally codified. I don't care about settlements. I
don't care about any of this. I don't care if you don't care
about any of these things. I only care about legal precedent."
So you said you need to substantiate that and that's how we started
watching some videos. No he wants no I love all of you. I'm not
going to keep getting interrupted especially when I'm there's
more but you do just ramble and say
understand you feel that way out of this conversation now just
I'm opting out you anymore I'll be moderating on your side.
>> Okay cool. So for the legal precedent thing, if you
could find that clip and stuff like that, that would be really
important because as far as I am aware and based on everything
that I saw leading up to it, and I only had saw it for like the
first
>> the I want to say like two months that this was going
on. But as far as I saw, his it seemed like all of his posture
was, "Yeah, we're going to go through with this court case that
these people can't do this, but if they settle, but if they apologize,
but if they do these things, then yeah, that will be good."
That was consistent. Please just
He wanted either a social or legal precedent. That was my understanding
at the beginning. >> What did he want? >> He wanted
individuals to stop maliciously taking content.
But you already said that he didn't do it to all people that
maliciously take content. Just people that he felt he couldn't
have a dialogue with.
>> Okay. Why did he say that?
>> Why did he say what? What a person that is rational
that if you have a dialogue with him, you're exempt. >> No,
I'm just inferring based on
just projecting that onto him. >> Okay. Where did he say
what? Where did he say he has no intent to do any kind of No.
If we're going to play the game, play the game. Where did he
say that he has literally no intent to do any kind of president
whatsoever and it's entirely out of sight? >> Well, no.
What I'm suggest I'm saying to you, Rally, is that >> Wait.
So, wait. So, he didn't say that. So, you're inferring something.
>> So, what I'm saying to So, what I'm saying to you inferring
>> is that you crazy >> to suggest that Ethan might
look ahead and think, "Oh, should I sue >> Asmin Gold XQC
or should I sue Hassan's orbiters? Which one's going to make
me win in the public eye?" You think that's crazy to suggest,
but you said it was crazy to suggest. >> Right as I came
in, you were saying you you were scoffing at Erin and saying
you don't think Ethan thinks that far ahead. >> All of
those various steps that she listed out. Yeah. No, I don't believe
you manufacturing.
Big word. I'm sorry the big words confusing you. All she's saying
is that Ethan knows there will be public support for going after
her son's orbiters and not for XQC and Asmin Gold. >> Yeah.
No, I don't believe this. I don't believe that's what Ethan can
figure that out. >> And to be No, to be clear, you said
that I needed him verbally saying what I
was raising as a >> Okay, so you were just making [__]
up. You were literally just doing something
[__] up. >> You seem to be lost. >> Okay,
so you were making up. That's what you were doing. Just say you
were making up. That's fine. >> I I brought an argument
to you. I mean something so that I could then >> I'll throw
the argument back at you. Where did Ethan say that he has no
intent for illegal or social precedent? He only wanted spite.
Where did you say >> I
I haven't even said that yet. And >> you said you said
question. I would say if you don't have direct statements, you
need other evidence. So really, you need other evidence that
he wanted to Yeah. So what is your other evidence for suggesting
that he wants to only discuss this with reasonable people? >> And
then Queen, what is your evidence for spite? Go ahead.
Well, I'd like Ray to just lay that out. Yeah. So, why why do
you believe he's only targeting people who he can talk to? Oh,
>> people who he can't talk to. Sorry. >> Well, I
don't believe that's the exclusive thing. I think he's targeting
malicious actors.
>> You believe that is the explanatory fact to why he didn't
go after.
That's what he said. That's what I'm saying. I'm responding.
Are you going to let me speak or not? >> Address that.
>> Oh, we got to We got to stop the interruptions, bro.
I'm in the middle of talk. I literally had two words. >> Sound
like you were going off track. Just remind you.
I promise I'm capable. I think we can interact with the other
person goes. I don't think it's like totally different. Just
clarify in the middle. Okay. >> Okay. Just just focus on
that. >> I I see where this is at. Okay. So, >> I
didn't stop you.
>> Go ahead. >> Okay. So, just to be clear. All right.
Uh, I believe that he is targeting people that he feels are maliciously
stealing his content that he is incapable of having some kind
of mutually respectful dialogue or some kind of uh conversation
or he can hold them to account in some way. >> You said
the same thing twice. This is what I meant by bloiating. So
I don't believe that's the case. >> No, you asked me for
my opinion. You asked me for my opinion. I gave >> So you
said No, I'm what I'm pointing out. You said the same thing twice.
Said mutually respectful dialogue with or some kind of productive
conversation. Those are the same thing. So what I'm >> I
said you could they could move he could sway him socially through
some kind of social >> so what I'm saying to you Ellie
>> is that there is no evidence of that because he has
not attempted to have a conversation with Denims Caseyron or
Frogan about copyright at any point. So why would we believe
that that is the factor that is making the difference?
>> Well didn't he literally have a dialogue with Caseyron
to be able to get the
>> We're talking about the decision to sue Rally. That's
the whole conversation right now. How would the set
time move? >> Yeah, prior to prior to the suit sue, no,
he he obviously sued, but then he had a dialogue with her that
resulted in him dropping the suit. So, that would infer that
if he's hold that would be that would that would show that if
this individual is willing to be able to have a dialogue with
him to be able to be like, "Hey, you know what? Uh, X Y and Z
concession, yeah, they would be able to >> they would be
able to drop the lawsuit. They would settle." >> Okay.
We have in the lawsuit itself, just real quick, just so you guys
know, we have in the lawsuit itself, this lawsuit is about ending
the practice of lazy reaction videos that copy the entire copyrighted
works and purposely siphon views and revenue away from the
>> So that is the precedent >> literally the first
line. >> Okay. Okay. Okay. So, so really I don't punch
in any direction, but you must this cannot be the explanatory
factor for why he sued Casey Tron, Broen, and Denims and not
Asmin Golden XQC, right? You must you must agree with that. >> Sorry.
Say again. >> You're using you're using an example after
the lawsuit has already been filed to demonstrate Ethan's reasoning
for why he delineated between different targets in the filing
of the lawsuit. You >> doesn't work. >> It's not.
So it's not just that the delineating of who he would. We're
talking about prior. If we're talking about prior, all I would
need to do is say that he didn't believe that he could have a
reasonable dialogue with >> uh what's her face prior? >> Did
he attempt to?
>> I don't know. >> The answer is no. >> Well,
do you know that for sure? Do you know that none of his her
you made the claim? No. Do you know that none of the H3 staff
nobody attempted to reason with Casey Tron at all? Because I
know while their their relationship was declining.
Okay. So, okay. Well, you just made a claim without evidence.
You said no. They did not reach out. That is a definitive claim.
Evidence happened. Yeah. Cuz there's no evidence happened. >> Okay.
So, hold on. >> It's a It's a negative claim, right? Lack
of evidence means that it definitively didn't happen. >> Quite
embarrassing, right? I I start >> No, no, you're saying
something definitively did happen. If someone says it did happen,
there's no way. So there is So you are saying something definitively
did not happen because there is no evidence at all pointing in
either direction.
>> No
evidence happened. So I don't believe it happened. Correct. >> No,
you said that it did not happen. Not your agnostic. >> I
don't believe it happened. >> No. Just to be okay with
no evidence. You have you know that it didn't happen. >> I
I don't believe it happened.
>> So you understand
this right now. DID YOU APPROPOSE OF NOTHING SAY SOMETHING DIDN'T
HAPPEN or did really say something happened and then you said
it didn't happen? >> No, I said I was agnostic. I said
I don't know whether or not it did happen. He said it did not
happen. He made
evidence asked me asked it. >> Really asked me did they
reach out? Did they try and have a conversation with Casey John?
I said no >> because no evidence happened
>> which is not how logic works. You said something definitively
did not happen. >> I think you said no.
You could say you believed it didn't happen. You could say you
believed it didn't happen, but the correct answer is I don't
know. I don't have any evidence to show that it did happen. That
would be your argument. >> Really? Is is is your brother
a >> as far as my knowledge? No. Why would you say no?
See how that works? See how that works? Wait, you see how that
work? You see how that works? >> Why should No, I don't
believe No, I don't believe that's the case. That's what I've
said multiple times. >> No, you didn't. You said no, I
don't believe that's the case. No evidence. >> Okay. So
if you want to just say that's your opinion because there is
no >> It's not an opinion. There is no >> Okay. So
it's not an opinion. It is objective fact. The answer is no.
>> It's objective fact. There's no >> Okay. I I'm
talking to a [__] Can we get somebody else? This
is insane. This is crazy. You just said no. Something definitively
did not happen because there is not. >> There is no There
is no evidence. Have you got evidence? Can you evidence? >> Get
somebody else. I I
>> You guys are having a conversation. You
>> Is correct. But he's saying something. Hold on. Hold
on. I'll tell you. I'll tell you guys exactly how it works. You
cannot say, "I think this could have happened." Do you have any
evidence that it didn't? It's like, "No, no, no. If you want
to use that if you want to introduce to the conversation and
not just say, well, is it technically possible it could have
happened?" You need to give some evidence that it's probable
that it happened, that there's some reason you should consider
it. Otherwise, shut up. Okay. But Queen saying that it definitely
didn't happen is also stupid. And he knows it's stupid. So, treat
it like it didn't >> I'm saying I'm saying
just to be clear. Just to be clear, I never said it did happen.
>> No, just to be clear, I never said it did happen. When
did I
possibly
don't have a real >> When did I do that? When did I do
that? When did I do that? >> Well, sorry. When did I say
it did happen? When did I say it definitively did happen? >> When
did I tell the purpose of introducing a hypothetical scenario
that you have no evidence for other than to obiscate?
when it was because I was asking a question as to whether or
not they reached out prior
because I don't know you guys are like a logging all these people
because that's like what you guys spend all your time doing literally
sitting over there talking about politics all the time literally
respons
I'm telling you you have every right to be annoyed that Queman
was not technically correct I have no he should have said I have
no reason to believe that happened cuz I have no evidence that
it happened Right. But then I think you move on. Don't really
talk about it. >> No, but the problem is he's even refusing
to say that. He doesn't want to have the conversation here. >> It's
it's only totally irrelevant if he's he's actually willing to
have a respectful conversation. But he's like, "No, it's correct
to say that something objectively did not happen because I have
no evidence in front of me saying it did." >> There is
no evidence. It has never been raised. It's been discussed extensively.
There is no reason to believe it
>> So therefore, it objectively did not >> No, there's
no reason to believe it didn't happen. OB
did not happen.
I can be super I'll be super clear. I'll be super clear. I am
not saying I am not saying it objectively did not happen.
>> And this is why I'm saying right now on that one being
so clear. >> I am not saying it objectively did not happen.
What I am saying is we have extensive information about this
topic and discussion and there is objectively
no evidence in the public domain that this happened and no reason
to believe it did. So this is the reason why I don't think this
is a very productive conversation is because
you were both
still not able to speak how I'm still not able to speak who was
talking for those seven minutes you were screaming for those
seven minutes. >> You notice how I'm still not able to
speak. This is crazy. I no matter what I'm still not for seven
minutes I had to I had to go back and Okay. for seven minutes
I had to go back and forth with whether or not this objectively
did not happen because I said are you sure that it did not happen
or do we like whatever and he's like yes it objectively did not
happen. I'm like okay how do you know that this isn't the case
because the point is objectively there is no evidence that >> No,
you didn't. He's literally just >> I literally did say
this is there is no evidence happened
to this guy. I can't talk to this guy. go talk to this guy
to do >> I think what's happening is that irrelevant you're
stating the maxim absence of evidence is not evidence of absence
so it's possible to not have evidence of something but that doesn't
mean it didn't occur we just don't have the evidence for it I
agree with that I think what you've been saying is Hitchens razor
which is what is assertive with asserted without evidence can
be dismissed without evidence >> when when did I assert
it that it >> well it's So, we're going down. We were going
down an argument. You were saying
you were reminding
how Ethan delineated between targets for filing his lawsuit.
Okay.
>> Your suggestion is that if he can have some kind of
social or interpersonal dialogue with someone, then he wasn't
going to sue them. So I presented, well, if that's the case,
why didn't he reach out to them? And you said, well, how do we
know he didn't? I'm saying, well, there's no evidence he did,
but we've got we've got no evidence. You never said that. You
said he did not do it. >> That's where we are now. We're
getting to where we are now. >> So, you can either keep
what do I do
for one minute? You can either get hung up rather you can get
hung up on the fact I said no to a question that you asked me
earlier because I believe that
presented that evidence could be refusing to have this conversation
in your face. >> You can get hung up on that that I said
no 5 minutes ago when you asked me did something happen.
I don't know what to do. You're
>> So now I
asked you point blank. I as I asked you point blank did that
you're saying it objectively did not happen and you're saying
yes. I'm saying no, it did not happen objectively. You said that
point blank. >> I I've just been really I've just been
over the conversation three times. You can keep rehashing the
same thing. We're at this point now. Okay. So, we went down the
conversation
target. I would I would have this conversation for 30 hours longer
with straight raid or or Jtock because they never did this. They
never did this where they just made and then when I
crime just have a conversation. >> I'll be I'll be real.
Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. Now, a disrespectful This is so [__]
Such a >> I agree is disrespectful. But I do believe that
to be honest during this conversation you've given like a lot
of reasons that you could just like make things up or or be totally
subjective. And I don't know a way to like handle that other
than having a different moderator or to be like rude. And I don't
want to be rude cuz we're friends. So like I understand how other
people might have the impetus to be rude when they feel like
you're sort of working on your own subjective standard. That
is my personal opinion on this right now. So, I I hope you would
understand. Shut the [__] up, bro. I literally don't
want to talk to I'm gonna talk to I'm gonna talk to one of the
other two reasonable people in the room because I actually don't
want to have a conversation with you anymore because you're just
trying to move past something because you're like ego tripped
or something like that. >> I love you. You're very stupid.
Okay.
You don't love me. I don't know why you're acting like you love
me. But for Jacock, I understand why you >> Oh, he laughed.
He was >> Oh, okay. I I thought I got dragged out. Okay,
Jacock, I understand why you would feel this way about my particular
position. I hope you can understand that from perspective.
>> No, I I didn't. I thought I got dragged out. I was >> I
thought you were saying you
>> No. So, from my particular position, >> Can I
just ask you real quick like straight laid out the exact thing
in in like very precise terms which you guys were arguing over.
I think >> I think this turned into either an ego thing
or you guys didn't want to actually argue the points. >> No.
So, so I >> I've seen argue the points a whole bunch and
I just expressed why I feel like you're not arguing the points.
So, to me, I feel like he had an ego thing and you don't want
to argue the points. >> Okay. So, let me explain my thought
process of why I didn't really want to continue having a conversation
with him and I think it's reasonable for me not to. It is because
when I pointed out something that he said something that both
of you agree that is wrong. You cannot say that something is
uh uh not the case just because there's a lack of evidence. That
is definitively not the case. I didn't think it was a big deal
initially, right? I was just like, "Oh, yeah. Do we have any
evidence for this?" Because you guys you guys have watched probably
a thousand times more of this than I have. I said this coming
in. I'm only operating off of a very limited window of stuff.
I've been talking about this way a long bit of time. >> Like
this makes this look like way worse cuz you're very set in your
ways opinions about how you think Ethan operates and you're saying
you don't have any factual information to go off of. So when
you're like really disagreeing, never said that I don't have
factual information to go up. >> I don't listen, brother.
I don't know why you think that I'm trying to dunk on you. I
never said that I don't have any >> I said you have a strong
opinion based on not a lot of >> Let me speak, bro. Please
just let me speak. I love you. Okay. >> I am not here to
embarrass you or to score social points. I literally joined this
because because somebody who I think is cool has a different
opinion than me. And I want to just hear what your opinion is
that brings you to the conclusion that's different than me. That's
it. I don't care if every single person in here thinks I'm some
loser whatever lner dude after this. I literally don't care.
I'm talking to you, right? You were having this segment. I don't
think we would be able to have this conversation like offline
or anything like that. and I thought it would be interesting
to have on the stream, you know, at the very least it's some
type of content. So, I I'm just asking these questions because
I don't know all of the facts. You guys have informed me several
of the facts, but many of these facts do not contend with the
the point of view that I believe that I have and at least the
ones that I was limitedly aware that Hutch had. That's it.
That's it. >> Okay. All right. So, Ethan talks about setting
this precedent here. When I pulled this up, you said this doesn't
mean anything to you. He says explicitly what he's intending
the lawsuit to do, to end the practice of lazy reaction videos
that copy entire copyrighted works and purposely siphon views
and revenue away from the original.
>> So that is him trying to set a precedent against people
who state the malicious intent to siphon views. Yes.
>> Okay. But I don't believe when you argued the whole
time you didn't believe he was trying to set that legal precedent,
right? you you were saying you have to find evidence of this
and then I believe it. So >> I would expect this to be
in the lawsuit. What what I'm looking for is a statement from
him that says I do not care about them settling. They'll never
be able to settle. I don't care being consistent in this position.
I want to set a legal precedent. I want to come after these people
legally because I care very much about this. You
just to be just to be clear.
It is it was from my perspective that what he believed is he
was going to do this to these people and that they were probably
going to settle or something like that was going to happen. He
was going to scare them and then that they were going to then
offer him concessions and that what he was trying to do was get
it to be on record that this is inappropriate behavior. Not necessarily
a legal record, but he was willing to make it a legal record
if they fought it, but potentially also a social record. >> Okay,
let's look. Do you guys have
>> like capitulate
>> Capitulate to me or get he >> No, he wanted if
they refused to accept the social president then he would. >> Yeah.
Do you believe if they refuse to settle with him that he would
have gone actually I'm going to drop it. I >> No, that's
but I just said that. What I said was if they refused to settle
he's going to continue with the legal precedent. However, I think
the question is would he allow all of them to settle? And my
answer is absolutely. He would consider this a win if they all
settled. Do you disagree with that point? >> Um, if they
all totally like said Ethan Klein has the biggest in all of commentary.
Yeah, I think he would settle for that cuz he's it's all about
his ego. It's all about getting wins over people in drama and
not about >> Do you think it's possible? So I think my
thesis is he lied about this goal to everybody because his actual
goal as a tiny spineless
is to actually make everybody admit that he has a big but he
doesn't have a big he's got a very tiny and so what he's willing
to do is if you'll admit that he has a big he'll let you off
the hook for this president. This is not something that actually
matters to him but it is his stated opinion. So, how is it not
pro or plausible
that or even probable that he just wants it on record, whether
it be socially or legally, that this is inappropriate conduct.
How is that not plausible or probable? >> Already was on
the record that all of Casey Tron's stuff was was inappropriate
conduct. She's been mocked for her bad reacts everywhere, all
over the place. If all his goal was was social, that's already
accomplished.
I don't I don't think this is true. I mean, the so the social
being like >> who was unaware that Kate was a was a copyright
violating loser before this lawsuit was filed. >> I guess
when I'm referring to That's fair enough. When I'm referring
to social, I'm not referring to people thinking they're a loser.
When I'm thinking of social, and what I imagine Ethan is thinking
of social, is I might get in trouble. It is possible for me to
get into trouble for doing this. So, I am not going to do this.
>> Yeah. Do you think I'm Do you think Okay. Okay. So,
what is the thing you get in trouble for? >> A copyright
infringement.
>> Okay. Do you think I'm actually concerned about copyright
infringement when I see XQC when he's willing to say Ethan has
a huge PP, he doesn't get sued even though his copyright infringement
is way worse. Do you think I'm actually concerned about copyright
infringement or do you think my actual concern is saying bad
things about Ethan Klein? Has Klein broadly gone after people
in principle or people who have gone after him in a reputational
way? >> I I don't I don't think this is an either or. As
I said literally the moment I came in I think this is a both
situation. Now again if you want a percentage then I can give
you a >> Okay but it's not then it's a mix. I think he
does care. I think he does care about these higher because he's
not actually setting any precedent here. >> Hold on. To
be clear
if they say he is a >> pee. So So to be clear I think that
there is evidence to show that he cares about it by the fact
that he's even having these conversations with XQC. He's having
these conversations uh uh to a degree with Hassan, right? He's
trying to spread awareness about this, you know, issue even even
outside of just uh uh these specific people like Denims and them,
right? He's trying to talk about these issues which shows that
at least to some degree he cares about it, right? And even put
in other content creators. So, it's not even just that he he
only exclusively cares about himself, but I agree that where
he's it's going to push him over the edge to lawsuit and stuff
like that is where it personally not only uh uh affects him,
but he also views it as like
uh uh
malicious towards or whatever, saying bad things about him. Yeah.
So, you think the way he showed that he cares about copyright
is to let XQC do all the things he said showed XQC was maliciously
siphoning views and to say, "Actually, you're chill, bro. You're
awesome. You said I have a big dick, so you're awesome." Is that
not an explicit violation of his previously stated principles
that he is going to file copyright lawsuits and explicitly let
off the guy he identified as the biggest problem doing all of
the behaviors that he identified as the biggest problem? Do you
think I have any reason to believe that copyright is? Yes. As
in when you steal my thumbnail and you steal my title and you
react to it and throw it up the next day with no reaction. That
is the worst thing on YouTube. Denims did not publish this on
YouTube. Denims did not steal his title or thumbnail, right?
Denims did nothing to compete with him in his standard marketplace.
XQC did all of those things and he said, "XQuc, you say I have
a big, you're all good, buddy. I would never want to chill your
reactions." So that wouldn't
>> it's very obvious to me that he has no principles on
this.
>> Okay. So I don't believe that's a comparable example.
I I know you're being hyperbolic, but I I think it is worthy
because it's not he's not saying he is a big what he's saying
is that or what he's doing is engaging in a
>> No, he is just not on Ethan Klein that Ethan Klein.
If you have a positive opinion of Ethan Ethan Klein, you can
react to any of his stuff. If you have a negative opinion of
Ethan Klein, you say bad things about him, then that's saying
he has a small, but he he is of the opinion that the biggest
transgression somebody can do is not copyright infringement.
It is saying Ethan Klein has a small and I am being hyperbolic
there. Yes, it is just about the reputational harm that he feels
like. >> Okay. So, so then I I actually I don't remember.
Okay, so don't again this is me fully admitting I don't remember.
Why didn't he sue every single Hassan Orbiter then who watched
the content
I don't know. I don't know what their reactions were like. I
have no idea. I've not looked at >> If he was concerned
with if he was concerned with their his public image, wouldn't
he sue all of them?
>> I don't know. >> Because he's concerned with his
image and he doesn't he wants everyone to suck their dick. is
according to JTO if you sell the E of the M. I think that just
going after three people is enough to chill it and signal to
people that like, hey, because if because we talked about this
earlier with the social precedent that it can set. If you all
you have to do is make examples out of these three scapegoats
and it signals to everybody else. If you do this, I will come
after you with all of this with like a lawsuit and I have all
this money behind me and you're not going to be able to challenge
it and you're going to have to um basically embarrass yourself
like Casey Tron was forced to um or face financial ruin. Okay.
Why these specific three people?
>> That I don't know.
>> Don't you think that's really important?
>> No, I'm not saying it's not important. I'm just saying
that it's not. >> Okay. So, the narrative is that he's
going after people who are targeting his ego and going at his
ego. >> No, I would make the same argument as if he went
after like Mike from PA and Shawn de Black and and Denims. He
probably should have gone after Mike for Mike for PA's been a
really really bad dude to him. Like said a lot of about him.
So why didn't he go after him? >> I know Mike from PA has
>> that was like really bad. He's he he was constantly
like playing up bad empanadas not being like a bad dude in a
lot of >> Mike from PA has tweets where he's like CPS should
have been called. It's a moral good. He said stuff like that.
>> Don't give him his homework.
>> Never mind. >> Wait. No, I don't mind saying it
because I'm saying right now I I'm saying right now that like
there's reasons that he could have gone after Mike from PA and
he didn't and I don't know why. But if I'm just speaking to Ethan's
motives, whether he goes after Mike from PA, Denims, Froggen,
Casey, Tron, Shawn de Black, Idubbbz, Ana, whoever it is, I'd
probably have the same inferences about his motives based off
the same set of behaviors if he acted the exact same way just
towards different slightly different people. Cuz I don't think
you need to go after all of them to have the chilling effect.
I think you just need to make examples out of three people like
a few people. >> So then you would simultaneous people
the worst reputations so that he could farm positive reputation
back in his
is a really >> but he might not have reacted to the content
nuke. I don't know even for have a worse reputation then in that
group of >> all of them he called for the assassination
of he he called Didn't he put a hit on a destiny?
Uh well I said that he was going to I don't know how to tell
you this. That is not worse than Frogan's comments about v veterans
is it in terms of the entirety of like >> Yeah. Probably
not. Probably not >> worse than calling for a hit on
>> Probably not. >> I I think I think to a I think
to a lot of people I think Mike from PA is wor I think you could
find a lot of clips that make a lot of people agree Mike from
PA is worse than denims. Yes. >> Okay. I I'll just put
it to you that we could go to like O or Techones like um like
Twitter feeds and we could basically solve this question. When
they on Mike from PA, how many views do they get? When they sh
on Denims, how many views do they get? I know who Nicholas Yoro
has been dialed in on. It's not Mike from PA,
right? I think there's obviously three people
any of those people as a barometer. Why would we use those people
as a barometer? I would use X2C and I would use are going to
be on. >> I would literally use the largest names in all
of content creation to point to >> Yeah, I would go for
too. >> That's actually you just give me
I'm pretty sure
apologized to Asmin Gold for saying that about his mom.
>> I think one because she was a part of this very big
lawsuit and it was like she was in the public eye and number
two because she said those like really bad things about his mom.
So, you think those were sincere from the heart? >> I didn't
say that. No, I don't think it >> Then wait, then why?
Hold on. That imply that's implied by what you said. >> Wait,
where does it imply that? >> When you say because she did
bad things to him, so she's apologizing for them. That implies
that those are things she >> Oh, sorry. Yeah, that's that's
fair enough. Fair enough. I'm saying that she did bad things
at least in the in regards to the public eye. That's fair >> Yes.
And why do you think she apologized for them? because she wants
to well it for the specifically in the settlement it might have
been because she was specifically told to but um probably to
just farm good social credit with as many people as possible
while this situation is going on. >> Okay. I I assume she
was given that as a requisite for settling the case might not
be the case but under that assumption let's say if we let's say
if we assume that was true why would that have been like a a
condition of settling a copyright case. >> Okay. So, if
we assume that's true, which I'm not even sure how good a >> friend
if there's a whole argument on whether that's true or not, I
don't want to have that argument, but if you assume it's true,
>> okay, if we assume it's true, then
um I would assume it would be because Ethan Klein believed that
uh part of malicious content theft is making up lies about people.
And then Ethan Klein also wanted to extend the the the
uh uh speaking about lies
or like malicious to Asmin Gold. I don't I don't know. I don't
know what would be the purpose. >> It's because Ethan Klein
wanted to engender good faith, goodwill with the Asenold community
because he wants public support. That's my that's my contention
that Ethan Klein wants the good the goodwill of the Asenold community.
And it seems very clear. Did he have her apologize to like multiple
different large communities then including like Moisty Critical
and [__] like that? >> No, I'm telling you
he went for the Asold community explicitly and this is all I
believe it's all centered around
online. Wait, who? Asmin Gold and Ethan
>> Yeah. Do they like each other now? >> Are they
cool? >> They do now. You sure about that? I actually don't
know. >> Uh I'm pretty confident that they're like good.
I've watched Asmin Gold say like good things about him. I mean,
I've watched Asmin Gold say good things about Destiny, but doesn't
Destiny hate Asmin Gold's guts? >> Yeah, but Asmin Gold
would talk to him because Asmin Gold secretly looks up to him
as like a father figure.
>> It's also I think it's not so much about like a personal
relationship between the two so much as it is that he need he
wants to curry favor like positive favor from his community and
he wants to keep Asmin Gold and XQC's community off his back
because he'll lose public support if those if those traders turn
against him. That is the core thought is there's a there's a
core of support here and he is doing everything he can as in
not suing Asmin Gold or XQC even though they're obviously violating
his copyright and doing far more harm to him than anybody else
right and he's going after very specific people Casey Tron Denims
Frogan people who are universally reviled within Asold XC's community
that like
he he threatened to go after Shonda Black he threatened to go
after Shondaanda Black because he got pushed
>> people were saying that oh you're misogynistic cuz you
went after three women. And then he was like, that's why I've
decided to add Shawn Deblack to to the lawsuits for gender equality.
Shawn, be sure to thank all of your Snarker friends for their
constructive advice. Then he gets push back because of that because
it obviously came off as spiteful. So he puts up another Instagram
story that says, "I understand my announcement that I'm going
to sue Shawn the Black was upsetting to some. Therefore, in an
act of superhuman grace, I will make you this offer. If the snark
subreddit, Taylor Loren, and Cat Tenbarge, I guess another journalist,
all apologize for calling me a misogynist. I will consider dropping
the lawsuit against Shawn for the same reasons. To be clear,
this offer expires Sunday at 11:59 p.m. Then when he gets even
more flak for that, he says he was trolling and he uploads another
story that says, "Sarcastic non-apologies
uh will not be accepted. Snark, I need a mod to sticky this post
with a heartfelt apology because Taylor Loren puts an insincere
apology." So he doesn't actually extract the apologies from these
people, but he also didn't want to go through with the lawsuit
because he was getting so much criticism for doing that spitefully
that he just said, "Oh, I was trolling." >> I would say
this is probably the most convincing argument you guys have uttered
so far. But for this for the spite at least like that being driven,
but for this I guess I would need to see you said a lot of things.
I would need to see the sequence. be real with you. I don't have
a lot of concern for your opinion on what is a convincing or
not convincing argument when another argument you make is I haven't
really looked into this at all. >> Then why are we even
speaking >> like I'm sorry I'm just like you can you can
deal with things but like you're saying oh you guys haven't made
good arguments. It's like you don't actually you haven't looked
into this. I just feel like it's really weird to condescend at
all which is what that sounds like. >> I don't feel like
condescending. I don't feel LIKE THAT WAS CONDESCENDING. You
don't believe I just said this was the most convincing argument
that you guys have made so far. I never said that every one of
your guys' arguments is just complete and utter. You guys are
all I don't like speaking to either. I literally just said this
is the most convincing argument that you guys have made so FAR
>> BECAUSE I YEAH, BECAUSE I DON'T FIND IT CONVINCING.
Do you think it's possible I could just disagree with you, JTO?
>> I don't think it's possible when you don't have a factual
basis to disagree
>> Yeah. All right. Well, we obviously materially disagree
on whether or not I have a factual basis to disagree on it. You
said you didn't. You said you guys have looked at way more of
this. I don't really know anything about it. >> That doesn't
mean that my opinions that I have when you guys present me with
the facts are inaccurate with the facts. You understand that,
right? >> It doesn't recognize, you know, more. So, hold
on. So, I believe like I can recognize So, hold on. Let me give
you an example. I can recognize that uh um Jackson HL has more
knowledge about foreign policy than me. But if we start having
a conversation about foreign policy, I could disagree with him
about the the opinions on the facts that he presents to me. Correct.
>> I agree with you. But that wasn't what you did. You
said, "Isn't this like you didn't disagree on facts? You basically
gave a way to inject subjectivity into the argument." You said,
"I'm going to treat Ethan like in this whole
>> This is literally the entirety of this conversation
is subjective. You would never in your right mind say you have
the objectively correct take. >> Your both of your guys'
opinion is subjective just like mine. >> I'm saying I'm
saying that instead of actually using like uh like solid facts
to base my argument on, I'm going to base my argument on I think
Ethan's like dumb and so I'm going to excuse it in this specific
case. >> Well, wait. >> No, you guys I'm going to
back up a little bit.
>> Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. Let me just respond to let
me just respond to that. So you guys are inferring off of Ethan
Klein's intelligence, his motives, all all this past context.
I'm just doing the same thing. But the only difference, at least
as far as I am personally sitting from and and aware of that
he's also quite dumb. And then I believe if you add that context,
a lot of his actions are very explainable. I think a lot of his
actions are very explainable. If you take all of this information,
I don't think he's very dumb. I think he's not like narcissistic
and it's makes him pretty. Okay, I could provide you some other
clips if you want to contest whether or not he's a dumb person.
>> Sense that I got is irrelevant. You came in and you
made it clear that you're not up to date with as much that as
like just I know fine.
And I'm assuming that and you're attempting to give Ethan the
benefit of the doubt that
maybe it he really you were taking him at his word and that he
is being genuine when he says his motivation
for this is copyright as well as
the trying to settle these personal vendettas with these people.
But in trying to do that, I think that you had to, since you
don't have a lot of information to go off of by your own admission,
you started coming up with scenarios um and potential motives
for him that are just highly implausible to me. Like, are they
possible? Could they technically be true? Yes. But I think based
off of what Justil and I are privy to and other information that
kind of undermines the motives that you suggested, we're making
inferences off of like other behaviors we know that he's taken
as opposed to where you're coming from, which is like you're
giving him the benefit of the doubt, but it's just coming from
like wanting to extend charity and good faith to Ethan as opposed
to like no, I have other actions that he's taken that undermine
it. Or you would say like, well, if he if that was really his
motive, wouldn't he have done this? Like you'd create another
scenario that like if that were truly his motive, he would have
needed to have done XYZ thing. >> That's how that works.
So you're So let's say I claim straighter that you want to kill
all men, >> right? That's my claim. You want to kill all
of them. Okay. And my evidence for saying that you you don't
want to let's say I'm opposing that. You haven't killed any men
as far as I'm aware. Maybe you can break some news here. Do is
that not an argument to have? Like, well, if your motive was
to do this, well, you're pretty at it. You're pretty dogit at
that. And that's a part of the argument for like why didn't he
go after Mike from PA? Why didn't he go after some of these other
people that he's pretty dog [__] at going after all
criticism? It's that he wants to chill criticism. And so, picking
a couple chilled specific opinions >> is enough to chill
criticism usually.
So, he's wanted to chill these specific people, but didn't want
to chill one of the big like actors that a lot of people hate.
I would say that I just I just have to watch if you were going
to go after Sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry. No, no, no, no. I understand
what you're saying. I'm I'm just going to cuz you just didn't
listen to what I said or you just kept going on something totally
unrelated. So, what I said was he wants to chill criticism. That's
perfectly fine. He wants to chill criticism of him. He picked
three specific critics and tried to destroy them financially,
right? Like he obviously was willing to destroy them financially
unless they're willing to humiliate themselves for going after
him. Say Ethan Klein is a very big Okay, so without that he's
going to financially destroy them. That is what he's saying.
So the precedent he's setting is if you criticize me, I might
come down on you super hard. Okay, it's not he wants to all critics
cuz that is not even feasible, right? And obviously he wants
to avoid blowback too, right? There's a submotive of wanting
to avoid blowback for these things. So he goes after the least
supportable people, the most hatable people who are his critics.
He wants to silence that, right? He even threatens a couple other
people who are sort of adjacent to them. Makes it very clear
what his motive is. And then
that's it. So he doesn't have to go after everybody. He wants
to set a precedent that hey, if you're if you're critiquing me
and I feel like you're going over the line, I will sue you.
>> Okay, cool. So what was I going to say? >> Or
you could respond to it, too. >> Also, on your metaphor,
I feel like >> I want him to respond to that. What was
I going to say? You cut me off because you said you knew what
I was going to say. What was I going to say? >> Oh, you
were just going the wrong direction. You did the kill thing.
So, I'm saying that's not even the point. >> No, that wasn't
what I was going to say. Can you tell me what I was going to
say when you cut me off? >> Like, if you want to shoot
if you want to uh dissident in a authoritarian regime, right?
You want to kill dissident. You don't have to every single dissident.
You can kill a couple and then suddenly the diss the dissident
behavior, the dissident rhetoric suddenly mutes, right? >> That's
not what I was going to say. Do you want Do you know that's not
what you're going to say
to that? Uh, I just heard you respond to straight raid about
all men and I was like, "Oh, I need to resp specify what I was
saying because we're not on the right track." >> Okay.
So, when you interrupted me, you said that you knew what I was
going to say. You didn't know what I was going to say because
I was going to bring up a separate point. >> Uh, if I said
I knew what you're going to say, I meant I think I know what
direction you're going in and I want to make sure you understand
my opinion cuz you didn't understand my opinion when you responded
to it 5 minutes ago. >> Okay. It's I I believe I understood
your opinion, but I understand that you >> So why did you
So then I have to ask you now, why did you say if you wanted
to kill men, you stop before you kill men. Why did you say that
thing that is totally irrelevant to the example I
>> Because straight rage a second ago brought up the fact
or that she didn't think it was relevant. She thought it was
irrelevant for me to bring up hypotheticals that are tangential
like, "Hey, uh, I have XYZ objective." Well, if you have X and
Y and Z objective, why didn't you do um you know, A, B, and C?
She said that she didn't think that that
>> Not that they're relevant, that they're speculative.
And because they're speculative, that just means that they're
you're arguing from conjecture because you don't have evidence
to base those inferences off of. You're just coming up with plausible
scenarios. >> No, no, this is So, >> I mean, they
could be they could be relevant plausible scenarios, but doing
the Candace >> what she just said. So, then that specifically
was what I was responding to. So I was not responding to you,
Jacock. I was responding to her. So you understand I wasn't misunderstanding
you. I was at at worst misunderstanding
You didn't think that I don't think I was misunderstanding her
>> cuz you were saying why. >> No, I was literally
directly responding to her. I was directly I was directly responding
to her because she brought up a point about the reason why I
went on to talk about Mike from PA. >> Um Okay. So >> So
then you agree he doesn't have to sue Mike from PA then then
the whole thing think that I think he doesn't see Mike from PA.
>> I think that is a problem with your thesis because Mike
from PA is a very hateable guy. I think he's a very hateable
guy. I'm definitely not anywhere near the hate of these three
>> especially I'm pretty sure he's hated. I feel pretty
confident he's hated more than Casey Tron. I feel pretty confident
about that.
>> Okay. So, between So, I >> believe that he's wealthier.
>> Mike out of all of them, Mike is a >> lawuit too.
That is true.
>> Okay. So is that conjecture and shouldn't be allowed?
>> No conjecture. >> The fact that he's wealthier
than Casey Tron. No, he is like objectively way wealthier than
Casey. >> No. Is it conjecture that that is a reason for
why he didn't sue her or sue
>> Um
I mean it speculative
it's not conjecture. Conjecture
it's based on like the facts as they stand. Like I didn't say
you have no basis fact
that based off of um
that he didn't sue the more wealthy people who reacted to it
even people who were like significantly critical of him. >> And
then the fact that mine is what is the fact that my thing is
based off of >> what is the fact >> one of you guys
has to be able to tell me this if you were arguing a good thing
>> that you that you think that he is more hated than somebody
on that list.
>> Yeah. So, how is mine conjecture, but yours isn't? >> I
didn't say yours was conjecture. I said earlier in the conversation
you were doing conjecture. I don't know. >> Okay. I was
talking about straight arid. >> No, I said earlier in the
conversation you were arguing from conjecture because you came
in and said you don't have a work like a really good working
knowledge or specifics about this, but based off what you'd heard
and some other things that Oh, okay. That I misunderstood what
you had said when you first came in then. >> Okay. No,
I recognize that you guys have a lot more knowledge on this.
Not that I have literally nothing to work off. And even if I
did have absolutely nothing to work, you would have to contend
with me saying that something that is a fact is not a fact. I
haven't contended whether or not something is a fact. You could
contend with my conclusions based off of the facts, but I feel
like I'm just You guys are saying you bring up that we didn't
contend with. >> I'm not My argument isn't that you didn't
contend with any facts that I brought up. argument is that you
guys are saying because I didn't come in here with as many quote
unquote like facts about all of this different thing that like
I can't even be a part of the conversation. If that was your
guys' position, we shouldn't even be talking >> based on
like conjecture. Hold on. To bring it to bring it back in >> to
bring it back to bring it back to what you said agree with on
that. >> Okay. Okay. So, to bring it back to what uh JTO
said earlier when he was like, "Oh, yeah. I don't really care
for your opinion because you didn't come in here with or you
felt like I didn't come in >> on what arguments are persuasive
or not when you haven't really looked into it. I thought I felt
like it was cont." >> Okay. So, then why are we even speaking?
Give me a reason to have this
>> I just when you stopped and were like, "This is finally
an actually good argument from you." And I'm like, "Well, you
don't know the facts of any of this, so I really don't care."
>> Okay. So, you didn't answer my question. >> I
didn't say I didn't have any conversation with you. I said I
didn't hear to like I didn't hear to have or I didn't care to
have like your
opinion on how all these things stack up when you haven't looked
into it. You know what I >> So then why even have the
you said is smart. It's like well I >> I never said I didn't
think anything that you said was smart. Is that the implication
you feel like from that? >> So I feel like you came in
here and you said you wanted to provide push back to what we're
saying because of XYZ reasons. XYZ being the arguments that you
laid out. We didn't find them convincing and then that's why
we spoke to you >> cuz I did want to hear you out and I
did hear you out and I didn't think they were convincing but
that doesn't mean that I don't think you're worth speaking to.
It just means we disagreed.
>> No, he said explicitly, why should I listen to you when
you're talking about a a situation that you've admitted you didn't
look into? I >> Yeah, but he says that after hours >> I
just No, sorry. I literally just meant that about the sentence
where it's like, "Oh, this is finally a good argument you guys
are making." I was like, "Okay, I don't that was I felt like
I felt like that was condescension. I just want to point out
that I'm supposed to
>> that way." >> Yeah. Well, I was just I was literally
just going like, "I don't want to hear that." That was all I
was saying was that that comment I was like, "Okay, I don't care
about that." >> Okay. Well, >> I didn't mean I didn't
want to hear it from you at all. >> I apologize if it came
off in a condescending manner. That wasn't my intention. My intention
was to communicate that that was a good line of dialogue and
I wanted to explore that for the purposes of, you know, trying
to understand you guys' position better. I >> Okay, wait.
Yay. We're all friends now. Yay. We're all friends. We're all
friends. It's all fine. Back to the thing really quick. I do
want to come I do want to say you asked earlier why did he go
after these people then and I totally forgot he Denims had threatened
to sue him for defamation because of statements that he made
related to her um for like saying that she was responsible for
the CPS call or heavily implying and suggesting that and he ended
up retracting that statement and she dropped the lawsuit. But
before that, he had gotten her and Frogan banned for 30 days
for the stuff related to the like what was dubbed the Hummus
Gate incident at TwitchCon. Do you remember this where they did
the like Arab tier list? So there's the motivations for launching
these lawsuits against Froggen and Denims in particular, what
he what motivated him to go after Caseyron other than her having
poor social standing and being impoverished. I I think it really
just comes down to that. >> Okay. And you believe that's
a particularly strong enough case for making your argument
um that
he is doing this out of spite even though
definitely the history is more there for Mike from PA between
Ethan and Mike from PA in comparison to Ethan and Caseyron prior
to this. The history is way more there for Mike. >> I'm
not saying that's the strongest argument for that. I'm only responding
to your question earlier that I didn't have a satisfying answer
to as to like, well, why did he go after these particular individuals?
And I said, I don't know. But then I thought about it more and
I remembered that those could be potential motives.
>> Also, it wasn't the only argument that I made at that.
It's like we're 2 hours into this conversation. Everything else
that every other argument I've made as to why I think it's highly
implausible that the copyright thing is really what's motivating
him is also part of the reason that goes into that.
sure. All right. Well, I feel like uh the vibes have crashed
and it's been going on long enough. >> No, no, no, no.
What was the point you said was good? And go ahead and keep going
down that argument. It was just the Shawn the Black thing about
him backing out and then coming back in and then backing out
and I was unclear about the timeline because I think that's one
of the most because if your guys's argument is that he doesn't
care about the substance of whether or not these people uh uh
committed any copyright infringement having the example of Shondaanda
Black him saying that he's going to sue Shonda Black but then
re retracting his suit because of uh uh public pressure or uh
and saying that well I would retract it if these other people
made comments that are totally secondary or tertiary to the prince
any principle of the case. I believe you said something like
>> apologize for their misogyny or something like that.
I could see that potentially being a joke from him. However,
I feel like to make an argument that that was like all a joke
and a gag, I would either need significant context from the a
video that like shows that when he said this or did this, it
was like incredibly funny. Haha, laugh. No, like very obviously
a joke or that I would need to make the argument that JTO it
sounded like thought I was making earlier that he is so incredibly
helplessly he needs a guardian, which I'm not going to make either
without uh more evidence. So, I would feel like this would be
a very convincing one if I had the timeline of all this breaking
down and stuff like that. >> I thought Jay-to was saying
that based off of the way you've described Ethan that by by how
like how much you were underscoring how dumb and like he was
that by that point that must be how you view him. Not not that
you were saying that your argument was literally that he's so
dumb that he literally needs a caretaker and and to wear a helmet
24/7. Basically, I'm pretty sure that was his argument to have
a reasonable conversation because we're going to treat Ethan
Klein like he's whenever we want with like no particular criteria
>> and it's like >> that was that was what I believed
his argument was that it's not >> but like realistically
if you're just going to make that argument and not give like
it's like you're like well I can show you he's dumb and it's
like okay but then we can't really argue about anything he's
doing because you could just say it's because he's dumb.
That's not true because that would require me
>> that would require me to believe he's infinitely dumb
and then I can explain all of these things by and if he was infinitely
dumb then I would just make the argument that it's all emotional.
>> But this doesn't really explain to me why after speaking
to a lawyer he still made the statements that he did.
>> I understand you I understand we just went through two
hours of conversation. I hope you can understand that. I understand
that why you would say that and I hope you can understand why
I would say the opposite. Right? We just had two hours of conversation.
I'm not under any illusion. >> I actually don't I actually
don't know why. So, hypothetically, if a lawyer tells him the
opposite of what he said and then he still goes public and says
the opposite of what the lawyer said, can that be excused because
of stupidity or is that just maliciousness? Like maliciously
lying? Wait, what are you talking about? Saying the opposite
>> specifically with regards to suing people and trying
to bring in stated malicious intent as a reason as like a factor
of why of like is a factor that's pertinent to the case. >> Which
statement are we referencing that he I I don't know. So for me
specifically what
what I'm seeing from him is okay. So the the chronology here
lawyer tells me >> wants to chill people who maliciously
just real quick sorry I have to I have to state it people are
we're saying he wants to set a precedent against people who are
stealing things maliciously stated malicious that they'll state
it's malicious because he he explicitly says XQC is good the
exact bad criteria he gave before that's actually okay I don't
want to chill that he said but I do want to go after Denim's
caseron and this person so that by implication is specifically
the state of malicious intent that's who he wants to go after.
But I do believe a lawyer would have told him that you literally
can't that's not legally relevant to copyright protections like
that stated intent. It will just come down to a dispassionate
analysis of facts.
>> Yes. And if he's trying to get them to settle or do
something like that to concede
for fear of losing the lawsuit,
wouldn't that work? >> Oh, so you think he's lying because
he's not dumb, because he's smart and he wants them to like concede
cuz he's No, it's not that he's lying. He he does want to prevent
the malicious stuff from going down. He just believes he'll prevent
it by having these people like concede. They're going to get
in and they're going to cut out or stop it. >> What's wrong
with that theory? >> I guess just that you're basically
going into a lawsuit and going to risk all the downsides in terms
of what that would happen. So he says he doesn't want to chill
broader commentary. He wants to protect them, but he can't protect
them if he sets a precedent against the exact kind of commentary
that XQC and Asmin Gold were doing. And I believe a lawyer would
have told him that too. that if we go to if we go to court, it
will actually undermine the exact things you said here that you
want to go ahead and protect these kinds of reactions, but it
will do the opposite. I believe a lawyer would have told him
that before he published the video, but he published the video
anyway with that exact line in there because he's a lying coward
who didn't want to get criticized for it. >> I'm not sure
how a lawyer would explain the line of how much of a reaction
would be. If I had to imagine genuinely my best faith analysis,
imagine a lawyer would say, "We can't guarantee how much of a
reaction that uh uh this precedent would set. We can't guarantee
how much of it will." But one thing we can be certain about is
that it's not going to be on the line of malicious intent. That
doesn't seem to be substantiated anywhere in the law. However,
the amount of reaction that anybody can do to a given piece of
content and have it be fair use, that is going to be up in the
air. And I could definitely see Ethan Cole just going like, "Fuck
it. We'll just do it. They're probably going to give up anyway
cuz they're [__] losers and they're broke." Just
just to be clear, anybody with two working brain cells can tell
that Denims did more work reacting than XQC did. So when X when
Ethan says he doesn't want to go after XQC or chill XQC, but
sues Denims, he is doing the opposite of what he says is he's
a lying loser. >> Okay. Well, hold on. We can go to a separate
argument, but you just get you asked me for an argument that
fits the legal, right? The legal precedent and like whether oh,
how could he do this? How can these be his motives? But him simultaneously
put up this uh lawsuit. And I gave you an example. All of that
fits. he would be able to push this forward legally if he thought
there was very little chance that they were all going to go through
with the lawsuit and or that his lawyer tells him, "Hey, we're
not really sure how much of a reaction or fair use these people
would be able to get away with under this system." But probably
but there is no legal precedent for malicious intent. >> Making
a crazy assumption that he would have like checked his parts
of his script with the lawyer. So he said, "I don't want to chill
XQC." But XQC explicitly did a less transformative reaction that
Ethan Klein that included all of the elements Ethan Klein said
prove that he intentfully steals views and Ethan Klein didn't
sue him and said he didn't want to chill XQC's reaction.
>> I don't know why he would do that. Why would he share
XQC's stream with his
>> He didn't share I don't know if he shared XQC stream
with his lawyer explicitly. He would have said this is what this
guy did. But I do know that he's aware of XQC stream that he
looked at it and is aware that XQC is doing a lazy reaction.
>> Oh, he's his lawyer is
>> Ethan is. >> Oh, well, yeah. No, you you see this
is this is under the premise that you believe
approached his lawyer. >> Shocking. But even Ethan is intelligent
enough to understand that XQC is at a lower bar than Denims is.
>> I I think for for the for the fair use, he could probably
recognize that. Sure. But for the malicious part that he thinks
is the really important part that he wants to snuff out like
no. And but the the >> But didn't you just say that you
think his lawyer public maliciousness part wouldn't actually
>> No, I don't I don't believe he talked to his lawyer.
I I don't see Where's the evidence that you What are you using
to come to the conclusion he spoke to his lawyer specifically
about not chilling XQC's speech or reactions?
>> Uh he said publicly that is his intent is to not chill
XQC's reaction. >> No, no, no. I'm talking with his lawyer
because what I think is most probable is he
and he made content around the lawsuit. So I think it's fair
to assume based on those two facts that he probably talked to
his lawyer about the content he was going to put out >> so
as to not himself >> about XQC's content.
>> I assume he would have basically taken the script to
him and gotten the lawyer to clear the script so he didn't himself
in his lawsuit. >> XQC's content. I feel like that's a
bit of a joke. Anything referenced in that script probably would
have been reviewed by the lawyer so he didn't himself in his
lawsuit. Do you think that's an insane thing to suggest? >> I
think it would be ridiculous to s Sorry, not ridiculous. I just
would find it I mean maybe you have a piece of information. I
don't I don't I think the most probable and likely solution or
idea is that he went to his lawyer said I don't like that these
people are just maliciously making up about me and I did all
this copyright. Let's go at these people. His lawyer went like,
"Well, you know, you can like malicious quote unquote lies has
nothing to do with this copyright and fair use infringement."
And then his lawyer said, "Uh, but we could look at the fair
use stuff if you want to do the fair use stuff." And he's like, "Yeah,
yeah, whatever. Just make it stick." >> There's a lawyer
in chat is potentially criminal. And he says he believes that
the lawyer would like to know about things Denims might bring
up as a defense. So things like, "Hey, you're not suing these
other people. Hey, you said this was okay. This guy over here,
this XQC guy, like you said this was okay. Okay. You explicitly
said you don't want to chill that. So now I have to compare that
to the people you're suing. You think that's reasonable?
>> That could be. I just don't have I don't see any evidence
for that. I don't even see him talking about it anywhere in the
lawsuit. I don't see anything I I don't know where you're getting
the idea that he definitely did this. >> I don't see XQC
mentioned in the lawsuit, but I I So my thoughts are you're going
to file a lawsuit. You're going to do content about the lawsuit.
You probably give the script to the lawyer to clear, right? Did
Ethan preface that his lawyers reviewed the nuke? It's not about
the nuke, your boy sche. It's about the video he did about the
nuke. Hey, I'm suing these three content creators. >> I'm
assuming that when he did this, I'm suing three content creators.
He probably went to his lawyer and said, "Hey, I need you to
clear this entire script so that I can publish it so I don't
myself in my lawsuit." Also, in that video, Ethan also said he
could sue XQC and get millions, but he never would because he
doesn't want to chill him or the React community,
even though he's been on the record saying that what XQC
uh does is >> So, XC wouldn't Okay, I'm sorry. With that
statement alone, craziest infringers that exist. >> With
that, with that statement alone, wouldn't that imply that he
is differentiating in his own mind stealing content and maliciously
stealing content in some kind of different way? Wouldn't that
statement in of itself show that in his mind? >> Yeah,
that was the precedent that he wanted to set. That was like the
new fair use standard and he wanted it to include this this intentional
malicious
um infringement. doing it was throwing
>> No, he he it seems like he wanted to throw a legal a
lawsuit at them and then if that they refused to settle then
the lawsuit would go through. But I'm pretty sure he was assuming
these people would >> Now we're right at the end here.
Okay. And so the only thing you have to answer now is if that's
his primary thing, if that's his huge differentiating factor,
why was he registering this and planning to sue these people
before he ever knew that this was going to be a thing that happened?
because he knew they'd be likely to steal the content and he
because he believes that it's malicious and consistent and he
wants >> in the exact way that XQC does >> it's so
he would m he would say he would make the argument that it is
different right even in that own the statement that straight
raid just said he said he doesn't want to chill the react community
so he views that what these people are doing is distinctly different
than the react community in his own
>> yeah but he planned this registered with the US before
>> they made any of these malicious statements about like
siphoning revenue or whatever. So, he couldn't have predicted
that those content creators would make admissions like that.
>> He I'm going to assume I'm going to I think it is fair
to assume that he didn't think that that is the only thing that
made these people malicious content thieves. That those statements
just emphasize to the general public and also potentially to
a court that these people are malicious content thieves.
Yeah, I don't think this mattered at all.
Do you guys different predicates for this? Which is they said
he has a
>> Do you guys think that Ethan Klein believed that they
were malicious content thieves before they said those
>> um with denims? I don't know if he thought that. I mean,
not maybe with regard to like the news networks, but >> I
don't know if she's done that with his
>> That's crazy.
And again, why would that matter if Denims did not maliciously
siphon views?
>> why would that matter if Denims went on a different
platform, did not compete with him on the same platform, and
never even published the video herself to the same platform,
right? Why would why would you argue she's maliciously siphoning
views?
>> Why would Ethan argue that? >> Yes. What is the
evidence she's maliciously siphoning views? Do you know what
the evidence is for that? Well, I I I feel like his his argument
would probably just be by her Twitch stream alone uh doing that
her statements that, you know, nobody should like be following
Ethan, he shouldn't have a platform and whatever, but still watching
his content that uh you know that by engaging in his content
and interacting with it while also simultaneously saying that
he shouldn't have an audience and petitioning for him to be uh
removed off all these platforms
>> she is beformed. pretty. So I maybe you guys could correct
me if I'm wrong. Had these people not been saying that Ethan
Klein should be banned for a while for his like pro-Israeli genocidal
rhetoric? >> Where did they where did any of them call
for him to be banned? >> I I don't I don't recall off the
top of my head, but I feel I feel pretty confident the idea that
they have said that he said he's done to things under YouTube
to in regards to his comments on Israel Palestine.
Is that just totally
>> I've never seen any clips like that. If they exist,
I've never seen them. >> All right. I I can >> What
I do know is that Ethan has gotten Frogan and Denim's banned
for 30 days out of who's gotten who banned between all of these
people.
>> I mean, I like I know what Denim's arguments are. Um
I or sorry, what Ethan's arguments are. His argument is that
she read a chat and she said, "So the chat said something like,
"Oh, thank god you're streaming so I don't have to give him a
view." And she was like, "Yeah, I'm going to stream it, I guess,
since he's dropping it today." Right. That's what she said. >> Yeah.
Like, and it like that's what he lays out the lawsuit that it's
like, >> "Yeah, the only >> It's not just about like
weak commentary. It's that they made a calculated effort to siphon
viewers away from him. But he couldn't have known that they were
going to make admissions that he would later use against them
or that their reaction would be not compliant or infringing or
like not compliant with fair use or infringing when he was setting
this all the way back in January. >> He from his perspective
he would absolutely believe that they would be that their reaction
would not be fair
because he believes all of their reactions are not fair use probably
if I had to guess.
>> Based on what? He had a conversation with a lawyer.
So everything you say I'm going to say is going to be mitigated
by having this conversation with the >> Well, I'm assuming
that we're talking about prior to like are you talking about
when he first set the thing up?
>> Yes. Yeah. That Well, sorry. I'm saying >> so
you're telling me he spoke with a lawyer when he first set this
up, asked him explicitly about the consistent reactions that
Frogs and Denims does and ask them whether or not it applies
to fair use. >> Yeah. I've So, to be clear, I've just never
seen somebody suggest that that Denims is like stealing his content
before. Possibly,
possibly. I just hadn't seen that before. Um, the reason I think
he adds the malicious part is also, yes, what Forgotten Jones
just said and what Sean potentially criminal was saying earlier,
which was I think the maliciously stealing, he has to include
the conspiracy to try to get the identities of the Reddit mods,
right? So he has this whole thing where he's including a conspiracy
with Reddit mods that he has no
pretense for. Right. He's just basically alleging it, saying,
"I think you guys DM'd and coordinated to set up and and funnel
views to Denim stream,
but there is no evidence." >> So it is neither one of your
guys' opinion. So it is both of your guys' opinion that Ethan
Klein had no inclination or no belief whatsoever that Froggen
Denims or Casey Tron were engaging in content theft. Casey Tron's
low hanging fruit because I'm pretty sure if I ever had any inkling
Casey Tron was going to watch my content, I would assume she's
going to infringe on my copyright because Casey Tron is the laziest
[__] that exists in all. >> Sure. So then so
then we can grant Casey Tron. So it is your guys's opinion that
not I'm not asking you whether or not it is the case objectively
that they committed copyright infringement. I I genuinely don't
know whether they did or did not. Um I'm not sure anybody really
does. Uh, but either way, it's whether or not you believe Ethan
believed that they were committing copyright >> Do I believe
that? >> So, you guys both believe >> I don't believe
that Ethan believed that Denims was creating or was uh committing
copyright infringement with the nuke cuz I think that was his
whole thing. He wanted to make a nice creative work, right, that
would be ripe for this kind of dispute. And then I think he realized
after like way after the fact that he didn't have a solid case
against her, so he registered the copyright for the stream. Do
you disagree with that? >> Well, he didn't have a case
that it's very it's indicative that Ethan did not believe he
had as strong a case as he thought he would. That he did not
think he had a good case against Denims because he added a secondary
thing specifically to go after Denims that he thought, "Oh, this
actually is an open shot. I actually don't know if I have a case
here. I need something else to go after her with." I also don't
think that Ethan had a particularly strong opinion about how
often Frogan, Casey, Tron, and Denims did or did not engage in
copyright infringement because I've never believed that they
were the primary target when he laid this trap back in January.
I've always felt like it was going to be a >> I know you're
not supposed to judge a book by its cover, but with Casey Tron
specifically, and I'm sorry, Vim, if you're watching, I still
answered one of his questions, but if Casey Tron's watching content,
I assume she's still in content. I'm going to always assume that.
I'm sorry. you just it's obviously about that all the time. >> If
you believe if you believe Assan was the primary target, doesn't
that kind of push away all of your other arguments? >> How
so? >> Because Hassan is very wealthy and he's I mean he's
not super popular, but he's definitely got a lot more support
than any of these other people and he's very very wealthy. >> Why
would that invalidate the hypothesis
>> Because your argument is that he's going after these
people because they're soft >> Well, I think he changed
his uh he changed his approach after you couldn't get Hassan
to watch it. So he literally couldn't launch a lawsuit against
him if he was refusing to watch it. >> I mean eventually
did watch it. >> I know. But by the time that he did, how
could he argue that it's it's because of fair use reasons that
he'd go after him when the reaction for half of the content nuke
was literally 9 hours? >> Yeah. So your argument is that
you think from Ethan's perspective he believed that Hassan was
transformative? >> Uh yeah. I don't think because and I
don't think that he >> because again if you react for nine
hours how are you going to sue somebody for copyright infringement
when their reaction is nine hours >> possibly and not get
laughed out of the room so he like literally had no choice and
so he settled for the orbiters >> you believe it was malicious
you believe it was calculated >> go after him >> I
think he asked
to watch it
>> sure fair enough
so then you think so you think of that then it was calculated
>> yeah you calculated he went all the way back in January.
He's registering this with the >> library for Hassan versus
these specific people. You said that it was he didn't sue Assan
because he was making a calculated measure to that he was going
to be able to sue these other people. I don't I just don't see
this >> because then the the CPS thing happens in March
and then I think those people end up off to the point that he
sets his sights on them.
But not >> and Denims threatens to launch the defamation
lawsuit, then he has to end up issuing a retraction to protect
himself from a defamation lawsuit.
>> Okay. But not Assan, not Mike from PA. >> If Assan
didn't react to it, irrelevant. And then for a long time, he
has no basis to to launch a lawsuit against him for infringement
because he didn't react to the nuke. And then when he finally
does, if the reaction for half of it is 9 hours, how could he
plausibly sue him for infringement when that's how long it was?
and after he'd begged him to do it multiple times because
my argument is that I think it's more reasonable to not assume
he was maliciously calculating well yes he reacted for 9 hours
so therefore I wouldn't be able to get the general public to
believe me on
not or on suing him so yes I have to just stick with the lawsuit
on the other people it was just probably the way that he sounded
in their debates and when he asked them to uh to react to it
literally just like yeah I feel like he reacted to it properly.
I feel like they didn't. I don't feel like it's this super calculated
thing. I I feel pretty
I don't know. I feel like my opinion about all of these facts
being that he's he just believed that they didn't react much.
And to be clear, he's not alone. >> Why would he register
with the Library of Congress back in January? >> Because
he didn't believe that these people would react much to it. They
would do their content thievery. because Hassan or sorry uh Ethan
from my perspective at least has had the opinion that Hassan
and company have been significant perpetrators of the chair reacts
and that they uh
uh have a specific hate for Ethan. So you have the malicious
uh reacting
of the the chair reacts that come together with the the hating
him. So, it is the reacting and then the malicious part with
how they specifically interact with his community and then he
got mad and then put up a lawsuit. I don't feel like that's I
don't feel like I'm speaking Chinese >> I guess I just
don't see that as responsive to like why he would register it
all the way back in January if he wasn't calculating.
>> No, it's that he knew that they were going to react
to it and if they reacted to it, he knew that they weren't going
to be subsidive because he believed that they weren't subsidive.
But in your mind, your contending hypothetical that you believe
is more plausible
is what >> it was for. It was uh he was going after >> He
was going after he was trying to lay a trap for Assan and then
>> it just he got these other people and it didn't work
out. No, he he sets his sights on them after Hassan refuses to
react to the nuke and then when he eventually does, it's so long
that he couldn't plausibly sue him for copyright infringement
when it's that long and he's already begged him to to react to
it multiple times and basically issued a license to Hassan to
do that. >> Okay. If he has sued Assan, do you believe
that would have been in good
>> Uh, no. >> Why not? >> For all of the for
the existing feud that the two of them have had for close to
two years now. Just because they have a feud doesn't mean the
lawsuit would be not in good faith. >> But you just ask
me what what my reason would be.
>> Yes. I'm asking you what. Okay. So if we are assuming
your hypothetical he laid out this this trap specifically so
Hassan would chair react to the nuke. >> Not chair react
but infringe which is probably not hard to do. like like 90%
of what I 92 if not 100% of what goes on on Twitch, on kick,
on YouTube streaming as far as reaction goes probably constitutes
infringement if it were to actually be adjudicated in a court
of
>> Okay. What is malicious about him doing >> About
using the courts like about launching a a copyright lawsuit that
is not actually about infringement but is about settling personal
scores. What's not malicious about that? It's a misuse of the
courts. He genuinely believes that it is infringement. And I
think it could be argued that it many I know multiple different
uh uh Hassan reactions would be considered copyright infringement
in any moral system. But I I'm just talking about from his perspective.
What? >> But Ethan is intimately familiar with what constitutes
transformation and fair use because of his previous lawsuits
against other creator like with other creators where he had to
defend his own work in a court of law as to why it still constitutes
transformation for >> And one of the four point tests for
that is did it serve as like a market
>> Yeah. And I think he could absolutely argue in court
whether or not these served as a market replacement. And I'm
not sure how that would go. And moreover, I know or I feel very
confident given even all of this these different uh uh statements
of facts, I feel very confident that Ethan Klein could believe
that he he would be in the right in this because that's all they
have to do is just say, well, could Ethan Klein reasonably believe
this stuff given the who he is as a person? My the answer is
going to be absolutely
>> Uh Chatty Nickel, thank you for the six gifted subs.
Let's go. Huge six gifted. >> I feel like we're beating
a dead horse.
>> um yeah, possibly.
>> Yeah. So, all right. It was uh good talking with you
guys. All right. Much >> Cool talking. >> Yeah. We'll
see you. See you around. >> Thanks for coming on. >> Bye.
We'll see. I think um potentially criminal was also thinking
about coming on. I'm going to kill 10 men and then
uh